[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the lord's day
what a joke i'm running late
what's going on troubleshoot gaming
hustle and motivate my man how my levels
decided brother so
let's get this right you know what i
mean boozy the clown what's going on
judo four four is that zab
that's zab judah too cool what's going
on we need therapy what's up
toto dope what's going on black conflict
x what's going on
pragmatic eagle what up necromancy
what's up what's going on oh man joe mac
he's in here he's holding it down he
said everybody keep it respectful you
know i'm saying setting the tone my man
gerald back holding it down
i respect it i respect it what's good oh
let me know if i look chocolate that
mango oh
what's going on i see y'all i see y'all
up there early get in the front row lord
roughness i can't do it like song what's
going on thank you also i appreciate you
brother you already know troubleshoot
gamer salute yeah man we got oh hold on
hold on forget who troubleshoot gaming
really is hold on you know that's my bad
face what's going on bro good to see you
haven't seen you in a minute i'm glad
i've been there hope you're doing all
right
vic the brick gaming i like that he in
the gym he said i hit a gym hard body
karate victor brick
i came across my feet on or on quest he
was uh playing zenith i seen you in
there we got to talk about that what's
going on oh look like all building
building one 808
i don't know i hope i pronounced that
right you know what i'm saying ain't
down scope i like that or you're on
target you know a point ain't down scope
unkempt hulk what's up you know saying
boogie man what's up we got a fun show
just the lords we're bringing it back to
the essence because um
number one we haven't done it in a while
we always have a thousand million
zillion guests
and we love it but you know we gotta get
back to what made the lords the lord
you know you pick up the messy blood you
know sometimes you just gotta get back
with your brother just the full core so
we're gonna start trying to do that for
y'all just at least once a month we're
probably gonna try to stick to it i
don't know how long sometimes big guess
you can't but we're gonna try to do that
for y'all just the lords you know the
cameo coming later that's fine but we
want to get back to it so we ain't
rushing intros we you know we're giving
y'all that that real essence you know
what i mean back to so twitch channel is
set to sub only okay okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna let on adding think about that
baron i gotta let addict know what's
going on with that so um yeah
jason ferrari what's going on
but anyway let me get rocking yeah we
got a lot of fun topics we're coming in
hot a little bit don't know the lord's
was up late we had a lot of meetings a
lot of stuff going on in the realm
behind the scenes
i bring the balls we already know but um
yeah we got a lot of stuff fun playing
so fun show i will be back
see what's going on attic i supposed to
kill earlier to solve last night you
know what i'm saying harry appreciate
you brother that's level one holding us
down george luis what's going on jason
ferrari what's up yeah we gotta make it
to the essence of the core group mix i
agree like
some people some a couple of um patreon
stuff told us like sometimes we miss
when it's just y'all like how it was
back in the day you know you got to come
back here the core members and all that
we're doing a thousand features and
that's great but you know dallas man
level one is in a building today you
know i'm about to let y'all do dallas
man but yo if y'all in the chat yeah i
ain't know who's spitting when i go
right now he's in there right now dallas
man yo support level one gamer subscribe
to youtube go to the website i believe
it's lv1.com put your stuff up in there
man so we can give y'all some love i
love fame and them everybody doing they
ding floor hugger the squad i think
citizen
baron
y'all got so many people now i can't
keep up
anyway about get these dallas bars and
we be back
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but
[Music]
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with the
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all are messed up and turned me
to an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i
and i get the blame still i'll be
running collecting them rings you just a
target when i'm in the range i was the
hardest to start regardless
[Music]
um i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this
love my city but i'm still by coastal i
got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing
but that's all a part of me being
accountable and they say i'm better than
money because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on the song with
me that's understandable i kill a beat
and they want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to starter regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you ain't gotta say
it i'm embarrassed for you i always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city
[Music]
you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
who
let's do it
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
mistake me for addict if i can imagine
it's cool to give you some advice and
invite your girl to your squadron cause
if you don't give her that option you're
gonna be single player like siren you're
gonna get tossed in the bushes by king
david royalty and not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's the
avatar
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
and we are live
welcome to the ireland's podcast llc and
the lords of gaming.net episode number
243. it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date and today we've got sony's
acquisition of bungie
dying like two impressions
mlb the show 22 to gay fast and nintendo
switch
and sifu
impressions off we gonna get to that to
discuss that
to discuss so we're gonna get right into
it oh they already started so let's
introduce the four horsemen of gaming
those original lords of the realm here
at the round table my calls with the
colemos my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict of the attic show how
are we doing sir
doing pretty good it's been it's been a
great morning you know we're gonna
see how that ends up you know
hopefully waiting here for four hours
how is it from the twilight zone what's
going on over there oh we won't be here
for hours if you don't have anybody oh
not so much man uh be be dying like too
for anyone that didn't catch that review
there is a review up
very good sir
so definitely go check that out
you know what's funny like there was a
couple people that didn't like my
comments on dying light like
no no
had an opinion on you
yeah
that i uh you know we had a personal
friend that thought i was a little too
hard on it i had two people dm me saying
i was too hard on it
that's why they're closed again no doubt
we gotta talk about he's supposed to go
soft on it because he got a review copy
right
yeah right he's supposed to go soft on
it and don't give addicts opinion it's
addict's world
exactly
and i respected it and thank you sir you
saved me a boatload of cash and i'll be
waiting for you
i was gonna wait anyways
glowing review and you would go away
listen i respect his opinion so as soon
as it came out i watched it i watched it
again i said you know what he's right
hey you're not gonna buy yourself i'm
not gonna buy it
anything else uh
jumped over for a minute what's going on
i'm here uh i have to do something real
quick no that that's about all though no
doubt what's going on macmillan.net in
the building way heck i see you anyway
and of course we have the most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer list for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the lord of clarity
and lord patron of the iron bank my man
lord sovereign how we doing sir i'm
chilling brother doing good doing good
uh yeah we'll talk in a moment
by me you ain't personally
he should have an extra title to his
name but the the activision jones yeah
i'm trying to think about we got to
update his journey too yeah yeah as long
as i get my diamonds back i'm good i'm
happy with that yeah that's what i'm
talking about
you know what's funny i never told you
this but what's up in school in school i
went to
school with a kid his name is sean but
he was like
when he was like
he came in
i was a junior and he was a freshman i
was kind of like his what they called
your old boy like you show the kid
around the kid around the world
exactly exactly so he was always this
very sort of calm and very placid kid
like very everything he said was very
like like like he was doing yoga
um yeah so what did i do um so i played
more um whatchamacallit record of lotus
for a game
this is beautiful it isn't it isn't as
tight of a game as your traditional like
it isn't as tight of a game as like a
hollow knight or whatever but it is it
is it's so pretty yeah it's like oh wow
this is what they could do with 2d
graphics now it really and again when
you don't you don't see graphics like
that anymore yeah so yeah
so that
uh we'll talk about sifu later um
and that's pretty much it i didn't get a
chance to try dying light so okay so we
have the good review from attic he'll
break that down um lord stuff shawn says
uh soft did addict get his green fraud
alert
alert it's not no he's not
that doesn't seem like you want to give
addicts
no i'm not i'm not doing the leg work
you want to fight
there was there was no color green frog
oh okay
what i can do what i can tell you is you
can be a little bit creative uh-huh you
can get some green paper and wrap it
around but you could just drop them from
a good troll car you know just grab one
over police hate when you're like yeah
tell you to make something bootleg
that's not the official we can make it
like it's it's a party light yeah it is
what it is it started off as something
different
that's it yeah i'm good we'll talk about
what i'm saying no no no no and of
course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka the access game
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who defends nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the blue and green fraud alert
movement oh be loving lord king how are
we doing sir
uh i'm doing good man i got a chance to
watch keith thurman after two and a half
years out the ring and he looked like
two and a half years
there you go
yeah
oh man legs he had the skinniest calf
placement i didn't recognize him for
just because the hair bro i was like oh
yeah
listen he needs that rogaine or whatever
the hell he makes something
but um you know he was in there with
mario's barrios if you remember the last
fight mario's barrios had he was
fighting tank tank is a little guy with
a powerful punch and tank got him up out
of there all right and um
i thought keith would get him out of
that i i predicted uh keith in six
oh no man keith is back to his body his
body is something's up with his
like he doesn't take body shots well and
i think it's from the position of how he
throw punches that he leaves so he
commits so much
that if you catch him at the right time
in the body that he's completely winded
this is the second fight where he pulled
his mouthpiece out his mouth
in the middle of a body shot and yo i
don't even know how he's able to do it
with gloves on to be honest with you
he'd be like oh
[Laughter]
this is not supposed to happen from
mario barrios because mario's has come
up from 135 all the way up to 147. his
hip two weight classes so he's a lighter
fighter going up against a natural water
weight
that's not supposed to happen right
right so
and i predict if he ever gets in the
ring with spence or olga's or or
crawford he's going to get certified
bodies zip him up and throw him out but
um other than that
oh man this game passes the gift that
keeps on giving back
shout out to um phil dominus maximus
aurelius spencer who uh got that life uh
uh achievement um
man
it's great to see
the the dude that you picked yeah
getting acknowledged it's your greatest
dream
yeah listen yo it's it's like picking
tom brady out of the giraffe and
everybody yeah i doubt you yeah
you gotta respect him now he gonna make
you bending me
but i've been playing death's door
my son
got so upset with me when we was playing
fortnite
what night saga we about to give you a
fortnight segment at this rate
i almost almost got my spiderman joint
right he got so upset with me because i
tell him stop running into the joint at
least let me be there to back you up he
jumps over there he's fighting two dudes
he gets down
i get up there down one dude but i'm you
know i can't build i'm i'm a sucker when
it comes to building he was so mad he
was like
the crawfish
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is the moment when he if he could
curse me out he would curse me out you
don't want me to be like you dad
[Laughter]
it was so hilarious to me while i was
like yo go play some switch go cool off
or whatever
but
i you know now
where it's tears to this now like
it's so clear
you can tell older players and younger
players when they're playing yes they're
jumping around they're building they're
doing that you like oh this dude is
crazy he's young as hell right
and you see me and other dudes we on the
floor just shoot him do it regularly
old school gameplay keep
[Laughter]
myself back in destiny yes you know
what's really funny what's up and i must
be suffering from a crazy uh
feel of tribalism what's that one sony
purchase or a no
feeling away you know i'm not familiar
now you're looking at it
on god i ain't gonna lie i was like yo
let me turn on this destiny and i was
just like
man
look at you look at you
savage that's crazy tribalism oh yeah
that's ridiculous anyway
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito spread
that relative to the roman iop not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to hear shout out to definitely
duke shout out to my man mr maddie plays
rocked out had a good one on the whole
um situation we're gonna get into as
well with uh sony you know activision um
check that out we also had a good talk
on um black history month stuff and
voice acting and games so check that out
that's what's up also talk about the
downgrading of the um
the gran turismo seven oh no that we're
gonna talk about that we are not secret
symbols
we are not a playstation podcast
you're ridiculous if you want to hear
about correction you know you need to
listen to sacred symbols that dropped
but you know what this is the one time
where i think we should have did that
state of play
you're ridiculous anyway other than that
also on the page y'all check out what
that exclusive hogue law came through
with the legal breakdown and just how
unique things were for this deal in
reference to bungie and sony check that
out top quality stuff for me i'm on the
dusty side obviously the last word yo
last word was fire this week
check that out my man marco style came
through huge division player and like
this was the data of division right and
we had him on he's become a destiny
player and he's getting ready for which
queen so you know i had to kind of throw
some little salt at the division
i was like oh so tell us how it was
transitioning from that to the game that
really got your heart you know
all right
i had to have my segment so without
salute check that out great uh podcast
obviously he was in his bag travis was
in his bag he was very passionate about
the saudi deal he don't like certain
things but we're going with the bungie
and sony thing you can check that out
and as far as games um dying light 2
played a little um obviously attic was
in he's rocking a little bit dropping
game pass no it did not drop in game
faster oh yeah yes it still exists it
still exists oh no
there's a there's a rumor going around
the game don't exist
literally the definition of people
saying that they refuse to pay for
anything yeah yeah yeah shut up
shout out to your mentor did you listen
to that other the last word huh would
you ex the division i'll be messing with
you wow anyway no because he
i had to get him put shade
get that he be destiny hating but he you
know when we wiggle
anyway so check that out it's up there
on as far as beat like i said that
demio shout out to hyde he got through
shout out to black magic you know what
i'm saying god down he got his quest
yeah shout out to black magic if you all
said if you listen
he's gonna he's just setting them out i
was helping him set up okay we're gonna
rock next week on saturday
saturday night get down saturday if
you're around grab that question we'll
do that we'll do the deal because
yesterday i was on um amazon with mavs
at uh uh frames per second okay and oh
and shout out to uh fame shout out to
facebook
xp uh this week
as well yeah yeah yeah yeah
and shout out because i've been trying
to get back into destiny preparing for
which queen
like
i don't know why maybe it's because i
took like six months off of that game
but like i actually enjoyed playing it
like
and then i played that loot cave thing
and then oh you didn't do this did you
finish it i tell you story about like
two guardians that killed each other
don't you i see you trying to get money
at the end it should have showed like a
guardian's bones with a gallo horn in it
yeah this is like a smiggle thing yeah
yeah like yo they literally
spoofed the loot cave and made a story
about it in a dungeon it is absolutely
you as you go deeper
you hear this guy getting more madness
and more crazy and like he basically
they get anybody on the fire team to go
get the loot and then he basically is
like killing them off well by what
david
it's
it's mad extra too like i i was hearing
and one of them was like he's wasn't so
tough when i killed his ghost
prime bungee story telling all that
dungeon yeah and it's so it's
all right so the first time i did it
you see you know how when the um the
exotic pops up yes
and
yeah so my butt i saw it oh exotics
and then i just seemed mad more of them
yeah and i'm like what's going on
you know what shout out to dj arnold
shout out to binge that put me through
it this is it's one of those dungeons
that it's fun when someone's never run
it and doesn't know what's going on
because it's all type of booby trap and
you can just laugh at somebody what's
funny is i i i was blessed with halo
diddy that uh yes he was like you know
he's like i've been with people that
people run through that he's like they
let them hit every trap but we're not
doing that do you have oh he's afraid
he ain't let the barrel hit you
i've learned through years of playing
destiny that if someone is showing you
how to do something and they ask you to
go first
scratch your head watch go go get that
go check that out well y'all are doing
that oh xena the lost city man it's fine
king we got to get on man we got to get
that well rocket with you you're going
to leave the lost city yeah
oh no i don't i thought you were talking
about that game um the reverse time game
i was about to say i played that one
that was just
you gotta rock it is outstanding we'll
talk about another mm-hmm yeah oh it's
fire uh i could say oh no
that's what i thought you were talking
about of television oh no no that's a
joke that you can play on your
playstation vr and esteem and all that
everyone exactly okay check that out and
then on the last one i gotta show addict
out for the last one um reverie dawn
tactics
it's kind of like um obviously a lot of
turn-based you know i get down but it
has like a banner saga feel but even
better art style and it's like you know
these elves versus the orcs but like the
the the all the elves like rampage and
pillage their whole civilization now the
orcs uprising and burnt down they city
took things like they got the
storyboards with the animation the turn
base is cool it's actually got really
nice animations for an indie game very
yeah i don't like i don't like the big
avatars as much like i've never liked
that kind of like when you do those grid
spaces yeah yeah i want my character to
fit on the damn space of the grid right
and the ui is a little clunky with going
back and forth with the powers and stuff
but the abilities are fire and other
things it's that difficult though yeah
it's
we can't grind to death yeah it's crazy
and uh shout out to ksi he says xena is
pretty much world of warcraft in vr what
style you use it if you use the double
you're using your skyrim when you get
the magic put your hand up throw it down
or you use the double side or sword
style let me know what style you're
using in that joint so yeah that's been
that for me but um we got some business
to take care of i'll start first solve
and then we'll let you go so yeah y'all
know what it is it is that time of the
month that lords of gaming.net
you already know we've been blessed to
have some amazing writing talent and all
that aspire to be great in the realm
it's always a competitive category so we
got to talk about who did that who did
that thing what did that scribe of the
month that i dizzy scribe of the month
in the month of january so um yeah like
basically it wasn't me no it was not you
because you did that contribute
to what was going on but salute to you
though salute to you
your guidance the direction to the right
but
the writers
i'm done with you anyway so um yeah we
got to celebrate so this guy went above
and beyond he had a lot of
thought-provoking pieces you actually
would appreciate him at it because he
had a good yugioh piece that he was
trying to tag you on because he knows
you love you gill he's good at wwe had a
good one i'm so done with that yu-gi-oh
game oh you're off the addiction now
it's over
no it's just like i haven't played
yu-gi-oh in years so there's all these
new type of decks that i don't know so
like i'll be sitting there
i'll fight someone and they'll kill me
in like two turns i'm like oh yeah see
this is why i stopped
but anyway he's got that he has some
good um articles on china and then um he
is the lord of isa preached this iuden
uh chronicles so any update on that
yeah it's been um because you know
that's the spiritual success of the guys
that may uh sukkot in a suit you didn't
always have to play that because i like
the ours oh it looks fire so look
beautiful um our scribe of the month of
january is also my man lord chris jones
aka sisters assistants to see you you
know what he is on twitter he'll be
rocking salute to him now he could not
make it because it's a union man a man
is a man of the union i'll take his
stuff
hold on you're ridiculous
he left us a speech
he left so that's the nickname so if any
of the law any long neck can't make it
to accept that i dizzy scribe of the
month you are allowed to write a speech
so here's his bars for what he said he
said first of all he want to apologize
for not being able to be here again but
while the lord spread the positivity of
the realm i'm spreading the positivity
through my work as a union
representative once again i'm humbled to
be selected as scribe of the month for
the second time in just a few months
before logged in i haven't even wrote an
article since high school so shout out
to cog for snatching your boy up i
strive to bring a uniqueness to my
articles which is why i try to find
things that no one else writes about and
of course i am the eu then chronicles
historious is dave what kickstarter
shout out to attic for kind of brushing
me off when i told him to look into
iodine before the game pass deal was
even announced smirk
kind of brushing me off what i told him
to look into the iodine chronicles
before the game passed deal was even
announced then he put smirk laugh out
loud i also have so much respect for the
lords i will continue to do my best
check this out can you like this as the
michael jordan of lognet to reach new
heights and make the lords proud
especially with the ultimate 2022 goal i
promise when i win scribe of the month
for the third time oh he put it out
there
he said cause i will
i will be here salute to the lords and
appreciate all the great and amazing
work each of each of you do play ps
sukkot 2 is the greatest game of all
time and he said cog he wanted that goat
emoji you know what i'm saying so we
gotta actually
you know what you should start doing
when people mess yeah
you know you should start doing people
miss
like let like you know how we have a
promo tab yeah
let them just make a video and you push
the video thing yeah that price yeah
yeah yeah let them get their balls off
right now
chris got some confidence in himself oh
no that's it he listen he only been a
few bucks
yeah it's off i mean we'll take care of
you hit him up in the dm and then solve
you guys not taken care of already
he came it came to me earlier okay okay
okay
okay
so we got some business
yes sir let's read the super chats first
then we'll get into other business so
let's check these super chats that we
have thus far
no
i'm watching uh raising kanan oh
that's great great show damn i'm behind
you i already seen the whole season
already
no it's been out for a while i'm late
man i heard they have to tell me now
yeah yeah tommy's the one i'm looking
for dude because you know
we yeah we we have things in common
wow
i'm almost finished with two no
i'm almost finished with uh uh ghost
book two but i'm doing kanan right now
paul's i know yo
i actually think kanye was better than
than the story of his son oh
okay we'll get into it wow
i still haven't watched i haven't
watched fitness it wasn't basically
power no i haven't listen i'm on i'm in
the middle of episode one of power i'm
done that that's literally one of the
best shows ever made like okay
just get this chance off disgusting let
me first off let's welcome to the crust
in the chat for nearly crazy lord gold
thank you sir
really crazy all right
then we got the brother fonzarelli
gaming member for nine months welcome to
the iron lords podcast brought to you by
sony
you spent the jay bari bars i see
oh yeah i've already tried to include me
with y'all fraud
[Laughter]
shout out to gerald mack member for 17
months all hell ilp salute the lords
it's really refreshing to see the four
horsemen of gaming respect yeah
absolutely absolutely
thank you sir
then uh let's put the crest in the chat
for lord bronze i declare a thumb war
yeah i remember two ones i like that i
like that
[Laughter]
there we have heart gate today five
dollars super chat salute to the lords
hashtag playstation there's a monopoly
hashtag put up in ring and game patch
hashtag delay dying light too that's too
late for that one
you know what i almost did when i heard
the bungie thing man i came this close
to tagging the president asking him why
is he letting this happen oh my god
they purchased the apartment in a
building and everybody's upset and they
even purchased all they did was just
save your voice for the topic yeah
that's crazy and we have sith lord two
dollar super chat thanks for
entertaining me during my 10 hour shift
um it won't be a 10-hour show but i'm
glad we could do that for you dad one
time he was able to help you out yeah
yeah for sure you could listen to a
couple of episodes back to back you're
good
[Music]
then we got played five dollar super
chat good afternoon my destiny brethren
yeah i could be there i swear i wasn't a
heretic no sir two days and halo ce
magnum and g i guess gallahorn g
g jally
already acquired nice so excited for
witchcraft hold on let me salute flame
for ben and knee after slandering
destiny so many times and now he's back
full force he's got his jersey on it's
good to see it's good to see you brother
good welcome home we're on the right
side of history welcome back home baby
we got oh also me and flynn got a um
lord's minute that just went live now so
obviously you don't watch it now but you
can watch it afterwards
check it out it's really good you know
what i'm saying so yeah shout out to
flame though to that neato
we have platano jay five dollars
guess look at lords happy birthday to my
son happy birthday to your son
absolutely shout out to him
then we got hearty chinese two dollar
super chat in ponyvision bungie is now a
banger studio oh messy messy
[Music]
then we have stitch two dollar super
chat funny i got my galley on the loot
cave back in destiny one shaming
salon you gally owners yeah in the loot
cave is how you get the new galley
that's a good thing though
then we got brett bingham five dollar
super chat sus
kamiya apologizes to microsoft and
gamers about scale bound then platinum
games ceo leaves weeks ago now kamiya's
showing phil love is phil buying
platinum games
relationship is interesting you never
know you never you know look fellas he's
a forgiving leader you never know they
may be able to work something out he's
got that lifetime achievement he might
achieve everything else in his lifetime
let's see
there we have it taj davis five dollar
super chat did any of my sega brethren
watch the senmo anime last night much
love and blessings to y'all missed it
but i'm hearing good things you're a
good thing you're hearing good things
yeah i heard it was good hopefully it's
not boring yeah yeah i got to see that
line get real life on let's go
then we got lord metro remember for five
months thank you sir the best gaming
podcast in the world iop cog attic saab
and mr skyward sword himself aka the
king salute thank you so much thank you
for a great show always absolutely
right then we have hold on we got a
couple that just jumped in
oh wow yeah
i got it i got it yeah yeah we got tony
bryant member for 19 months thank you
sir
great to be here live play nobody save
the world and also watch reacher on
prime tv i heard reacher is good too
best show out right now
i think the dude that plays jack reacher
is uh the dude that played aquaman in
the um
in the smallville show no doubts i got
the boxing burger in the chat i see you
black guy what's going on
then we have hollywood rules five
dollars for the chat left the lord's
house to be welcomed by addicts saying
him and tommy have things in common
because they got the one thing in common
that's his dude that's his dude he
rocked he rockets i like to have the
character there we go gabriel forte
member for 26 months
i guess destiny isn't a terrible game
proud of the community for posting their
stats last week i knew there were some
closet fans in this community
it's funny they always come back 14. you
know we don't even say that about it oh
he's got literally people that says
destiny's a bad game and they've put
over 500 hours yesterday
there's a lot of exposure
after after slo-mo posted his hours
slow-mo if you're watching this yeah
stop the capping yeah
oh bro oh my god i saw that i was like
how much does he have in there it was
like 300 hours or so
because he is division hours too you
will never ever
see me put 300 hours into madden and
then say it's a bad game like
exactly salute yeah i won't say dustin's
baggage just enough yeah you i got
footage of you playing with us so i
guess we got you okay we got you
double digit daddy i appreciate
everything y'all do and y'all will
always have at least one fan as long as
i'm done
daddy whoa
yeah
it could be not feeling like not feeling
that alliteration
i feel like we've gotten to the point
where people are just doing this people
are changing their name every week to
have solved reading
it could be
it could see
y'all y'all thinking something else he
could be double digits sugar daddy yeah
[Laughter]
we were talking about destiny i got that
uh the sword from from halo oh nice nice
yes
[Music]
opinionated 2 super chat inferno in the
building inferno what's going on salute
then we have kool-aid 117 20 super chat
king making so much sense right now
after the bungee acquisition i hereby
pledge my loyalty to the king oh wow
sony is out the hardware game now sorry
for the doubt please don't stop to all
my iop fan much respect thank you
you're gonna love me today
those are good then we have gabriel
forte two dollars with that and for
tradition i was waiting for this
boo
hey for today
right on cue the tradition continues
let it roll yeah
destiny is bad but it's our bad send
help no no no no
you got the drugs we gave you your
satisfied customers
he hasn't been back for a while so
welcome back god's hit back
i've been thinking about like with the
starting screen doing something
community based with it we might have to
actually look into that yeah we gotta
figure it out shout-out to godzilla give
me god's help
oh no
he's been pre-destined
[Laughter]
that does sound like a boxer nickname or
something yeah yeah
it's so much i could go with that we
could go so left with it i'm trying to
move on continue
there we go five dollars will be said i
personally think that sony will keep all
the games that bungie makes timed
exclusives just like they did with
destiny 1. oh
we'll read the statements
we'll get into that
then we have
hard to find two dollars which i'm a
member for 10 months y'all double digits
oh
thank you
we needed that
we got g master seven two dollars would
be chat salute salute i hope you're
going so hard much love fam
you know foreign
some of the stuff we've been reading
it's i think paul's at this point it's
just irrelevant yeah
past the point of pause yes
the vatican has an assassin
straight out the finchy
you know what that is that is a that is
a lot more of a serious statement than
you think it is
right
[Laughter]
thank you to this wonderful community
that we have so uh we're about to give
away these uh these monthly giveaways
i didn't i didn't pay the bills with the
birch sorry um okay real quick yeah do
that so i'm shout out to someone who
didn't put their name anonymous he got
the blue dark blue for the winter you
got the beating the iop beatty
see rocking that beam
got it in blue then shout out to another
anonymous he also got the blue iop
classic t
hold on we got somebody bought the all
over prince jogging somebody got the
sweats
i was gonna wear i was gonna wear you
know oh see there we go new york the new
york june but here we go iop overrode
that right dude
salute this whoever brought those
joggers and then he also copped that up
beanie that one exact one that king got
and then someone got that white
10k
premium vest tee that our lord of
merchandise has not taken down yet uh uh
uh i spoke i spoke to the purveyor
the lord
listen i was just
removed
it's your responsibility
you do realize king that we're almost at
12k
hey hey i spoke to the old man last
night man
stop coming at me man it's not like i
got that apartment to take it off the
door was the 10k classic crudet
sweatshirt
he brought the classic t oh he got the
unity one with all the system colors
i'm a mailman and it makes my day when i
can listen to your podcast when i'm
walking delivering me yo
that's what's up oh salutes a little bit
much love that was the last one of the
merch now we can do the patreon stuff no
doubt so let's get into these uh patreon
giveaways and we have our first ten
dollar gift card giveaway
and it goes to
i'm gonna read the government guess all
this here
mark liberto
i think i know him yeah yeah yeah he'll
be right he'll be rapping salute no
doubt congratulations mark alberto
in the dms
all right then we have this 20 gift
[Music]
but before we read the next patreon you
have to read the newest member of the
the latest member of the round wow
remember for now i got it i got it
remember for nine months
amber for nine months which means i have
an ilp baby about to pop out i hope he
have saab's voice
hold up i gotta look around like
i hope i hope that situation is on the
right side of the fence
listen judgment free zones
love solving all your heart hey listen
i understand that he's battery listen
hey
oh
[Laughter]
daddy saw finna grab that crystal d
we have devolved into something else
you're completing something else
you did that who did that for you
the podcast's gonna end he's gonna have
that exact username follow him on
twitter
oh no then i'll be after dark early
continue song
all right let's see let's go to super
chat um
origins of a villain hard
we have hard to find five dollars i
expect not to hear a single word about
double digit daddy and sport
see i was the only one that first
thought the davis question ah okay and
smitty smith says and saab you are the
father
shout out to maury povich shout out to
you guys
all right so let's get this tee spring
trip our final giveaway for the month of
february
and
the winner of the tea spring trip is
we got what we got
why is it still it's taking big
shout out to you sir uh yeah i will get
at you guys in your dms or your emails
to see uh how you guys want me to ship
this stuff out to you but once again as
we do every single month thank you so
much for the support guys it grows every
single month you guys are amazing uh we
could not do this without you guys so
thank you no doubt you already know
thank you so much take care that's get
the poke at the tops get all going last
week's results are in and the people
have spoken out of all the recently
removed rumored game studios leaks which
one of these would you prefer to happen
first for xbox the winner of an
extremely close four-way poll at 33 of
the vote was the gears of war marcus
phoenix collection group
coming in at second place at 25 percent
of the vote was the xbox exclusive
rumored co-op monster hunter group
in a razer close third place 24 right
behind the 25 was the halo infinite
battle royale mode or was on spinoff and
in last place 60 revolt was the messy
lords i don't care it's still all about
this call of duty exclusivity though so
shout out to all the lords who
participate lord addict man what you
think they did the realm
what's that uh that marcus phoenix
collection man where you at i mean it is
what it is you know sometimes people are
wrong and they just want to admit it so
i'm assuming the fable delegation has
something to say about this no the the
fable council does not appreciate
the marcus phoenix okay let everybody
eat not just the gears fans yeah
everybody not just a halo fan hey look
it's a 10-year game i feel that i've had
to wait 15 years for a new favorite i
respect that i respect it that that's
real that's addict's world for real on
that one but that yeah that's good maybe
if they should support it two more
of them
anyway move it all you got to get into
these topics now that king this is up
this is the big one would you like me to
set this up sir
yes i would love so all right so
i got that
i was going to suggest that if if king's
okay if we just go ahead and do the
dying light to thing because i don't
know if i could stay the whole podcast
okay okay oh yeah again let's let's
let's let's get to the point
i didn't realize that was limited so
what's up man like got that review
up on iron doors podcast right now what
are we feeling sir
it's
look okay all right first off let's talk
about the elephant room the bugs that's
in the game
there's a lot of them it's definitely
bug lying too
but no dying like bug light too there
you go
i'm not gonna say that
it justifies the review score because i
do feel like it's still a solid eight to
eight point five like i i never felt
like when i when any of these glitches
happened that like it completely ruined
my experience it was just like
it was one of those scenarios where it's
like oh man i gotta restart this
checkpoint or something like
yes multiple times but even the sound
glitch like look as much as annoying as
that is
not one time a sound glitch happened
that you know what i said king i'm done
and uninstalled the game i didn't do
that because i enjoyed the gameplay i'm
not saying excuse these people for how
they launched the game okay
it's definitely not uh acceptable and if
you feel like you need to just go ahead
and wait for this game to to go on sale
or something uh because at the end of
the day we do need to stop rewarding
developers that do launch broken games
by you know purchasing their game
uh but i am going to say that if you
enjoyed dying light 2
at the original dying light and it was
something that really you know gave you
a good time like i i i suggest that you
know when this when you feel comfortable
you know google google died like two
patch notes
make sure that the majority of these
bugs have been fixed and then jump into
it because i do think it is it's a very
worthy game and i just i just don't
understand some of the media's concept
on it because it's just like
like i see people giving it like six
five out of tens because of the bugs but
then it's bad but if you look at it it's
the same outlets that gave
cyberpunk a 9 out of 10.
like it's just like i just and i get it
these these aren't reviewed by the same
people for the most part but it's just
like
the inconsistency with the the the
websites in general it's just like how
do you not see
cyberpunk being this broken
but you're willing to overlook something
like the um
something like uh cyberpunk and you're
overlooking like battlefield
4 when it launched no one really said
nothing like i just i just don't like
that like i feel like
and i'm not saying everyone right but i
do feel like some of the media
look at
some developers and if they're not huge
they're willing to overlook some uh
they're not willing to overlook like for
instance
when when we have these broken games
after broken games
all you keep seeing is they talk about
the positives the positives
like like i said cyberpunk like if if we
wouldn't have known you know who really
told us cyberpunk was broke it was the
influencers it wasn't the media like the
media was on some side in fairness
a lot of them were reviewing the pc
version for somebody i was told the pc
version was buggy too and you didn't see
nothing but not to the extent the
console version was we have to say like
i i will literally see people on talking
about dying light 2 they will be talking
about the they'll be playing the pc
version and bring up the bugs in the
console versions i mean i heard a lot
about the bugs and the pc version as
well but the thing was that the the
score still didn't reflect it it was
like it's buggy
but what they have here is still great
enough that i'm going to rate it higher
and it you know and and and then i just
who had took umbrage with that because
it's like okay no then it's not really
as good as what you're saying because
these things do exist
and it's like you know
i don't want to act like this is an
attack on the media because it's not but
it's like
i got to be truthful about it because
it's just like when we're sitting here
like i don't know how things go about
and you know people want to dm me and
educate me on the matter that's fine but
all i see is you get a game like
cyberpunk you get a game where they put
pretty much
lock people away when it came to uh
metal gear solid five remember
it's like you get these bare bone games
and you get these buggy games like
cyberpunk and they get these crazy
scores but when it comes to dying like
tuna i really think it's because a lot
of these people were like it's techland
what techlang going to do to us
we can really go in on these bugs and we
can make an example of tech land and we
could be fine but when it comes to
big corporations such as kunami or big
corporations such as i mean i guess cd
projekt red has
has like elevated itself to like
you're gonna want to review witcher 3 4
right like i just i just don't get how
we can we could shine lights on other
buggy games but when it comes to dying
light 2 we want to talk about the bugs
more than anything else like it's just
like and if you look at dying light one
to dying light two it is so
much better of a game and and i could
i even said in my review don't buy this
game until it's fixed okay but it i just
don't understand how it's a five out of
ten
like because of bugs that means they
removed five points because they didn't
like that let me ask you this and again
and out of fairness what if someone's
experienced you know they literally
could not play or it was like so
debilitating that it
is when they when they talk about the
bugs they had they didn't really
list any bugs that that is just out of
this world like there are some people um
our friend uh travis and ibm he said
that there was some playstation 4 users
at ign that was having that game deleted
that is worthy of giving it a 560 but
just offer the strength that that exists
can we at least say overall that if the
majority of people are experiencing some
level of bug that should affect that's
fine that's fine but if you're not
having those issues in that particular
review like i get that bringing it up
like bring it up to your audience say
look
there's been reports that the game's
been deleted that's fine but don't act
like their opinions is your opinions
like just because other people are
having a little bit more bugs than rest
like i i really do i really feel like
sometimes
that if if a game isn't that like i i
feel like there's tears of games you
know whatever yeah you talk about that
game is yeah if that game isn't above
that middle tier sometimes these medias
they'll just they'll just let's get them
let's get them boys
and i it's just like i i even said that
this game shouldn't be bought until it's
fixed but in no way if i were to give
this game it'd be like an eight out of
ten like i don't understand how people
were giving up this five six quick
questions king had his hand raised okay
for hours to get his king he's gonna get
a good kick but are you gonna are you
gonna go get go into him i just wanna
have a real quick question about did did
you get a patch
during your play session did you get
that one patch
um yes
you did okay
absolutely
okay okay there you go okay okay all
right well a couple of things one
everybody that i heard review the game
shout out to um
uh 2xp uh everybody that uh reviewed the
game they said the game is fun
and the bugs didn't uh deter them from
playing the game but again you guys are
reviewers uh this is one reason why i
definitely would not want to review
anything i don't care how much i want to
play the game i i that's just me yeah
all right just give me a finished
product
but at the same time
why don't we go back to how game pro
very simply and very eloquently rated
games
graphics
gameplay
sound fun factor okay that's it
not all this uh
ambiguous uh uh how i feel i'm so sick
and tired of all these reviewers and how
they feel
let's just get to
because i don't care about it like i
really don't care about it
see this this is the part this is the
part all right the opinions lead to this
bs that's going on right now okay
graphics how's the graphics in it i mean
you can give your whole soliloquy on
what you feel i don't care i just go to
the bottom of your review and if i care
to read you
listen to your review or watch a review
fine cool
graphics what do you rate the graphics
uh what do you rate the sound what do
you rate the game play and what do you
rate the fun factor and that within
itself will tell me exactly what i get
from that part right there and then you
can put in your little post notes down
at the bottom pro tips
remember that
don't agree with that because but i do
feel like that is their opinion and
they're entitled to their viewers
literally
yeah
i would like is a little bit more
consistency on when we talk about buggy
games like we can't go from one thing
because it's really hype like cyberpunk
and overlook a lot of the key issues to
the game and there's a lot of things in
the core wrong with cyberpunk before
they fixed it but when it comes to dying
by two we're gonna we're we're gonna
pick the the the it's like we're gonna
highlight the bugs instead of talking
about the game and note that they're
about
all the patches and everything come out
and and then because a game after all
the patches and everything comes out
it's just oh now it reaches new heights
oh i've it wasn't like that when i
played and your opinion becomes mute
then at that point in time because this
is the thing that that's the weight
the way it got separated like for game
pro like you say right everything there
is everything there can be gleaned from
facts right graphics whatever as soon as
you get to fun factor that's subjective
subjective yeah that's completely
subjective so at that point everybody i
heard have fun with it though but if
you're fun if the fun factor for you is
affected by the fact that it crashes a
million times that's right that's where
you put it at the bottom at the bottom
right and and it stands separate but at
the same time that no matter where you
put it that that could affect a person's
overall feeling on the game but like i'm
not getting just because of that right
it could be the most beautiful most
beautiful like
running like crap game ever and you make
that decision right you make that
decision but i just think people i don't
know i don't know
i think let me give you this let me
cyber bunk get we put cyberpunk in the
bushes like we did yeah
we did we
i'm saying that when you was looking at
reviews when that game first dropped out
it's like a 9-1 for the longest time it
was i this man don't like that no but i
think i know what your point is though
let me let me get right it's just the
consistency and not talking about the
bugs right one game you sit there and
gloat about how much fun you had when
the game is literally almost unplayable
but the next game you're like yo it was
it was it was fun it was great and it's
like they'll talk for 10 minutes about
how good the game was talk for 30
seconds on how buggy it was and it's
eight it's a five out of ten right
look rules reviews objective all i will
say is what i think some of the point
frustration you may have is that
the review is it too much cons too much
too much listing of the bugs and not
about the actual gameplay experience as
is okay
it's about the non-consistency
consistency when they talk about bugs
from one game to another like
it's just like look at the master chief
collection example that game was one of
the most buggy games in existence right
people didn't bring those bugs up that
much
it literally got like i don't remember
that bro
no no people but no but when you look at
the reviews and the reviews standpoint
that game is sitting at a 8485
now
you know a lot of people went back to
re-review i know i know ryan went back
to re-review it right there's a lot of
people who went back to readdress it
afterwards which is what you know a game
like that that's constantly sort of
evolving and changing or whatever
hold up shout out to hip-hop in the
building salute bro you say y'all gotta
show love to the lord's run god bless
keep shining something
true it's always good to see hip hop in
the building salute gotta get him in
there yes sir look um let me let me just
jump in real quick too you just want to
hear what i'm going to say about that
look i i i got it up now people are
giving it a a a 100 a 95 92 9 85. these
are all in 2014.
and this is one of the most buggy games
in existence
and people ignored all of them and
that's why you don't put your all your
stock on the metacritic open critic
stuff because we we all know like things
are subjective things can be manipulated
the system can be manipulated so at the
end of the day you go to who
you trust
as a reviewer
if you're gonna hold on if you're gonna
get yourself worked up and upset about
random dude at a site and then let's be
real each site is not the same person so
it's like you're going to work yourself
up for no reason like at the end as long
as to me it's like i'm going to you i'm
trusting addict's opinion and i know how
he feels about regardless and you go to
that person but if you're going to get
yourself worked up about i'm not working
i'm worked up about everything i'm
passionate about everything i speak
about clearly these bugs is an issue
the way they talking about them
but that's all i'm saying it's like i
just personally feel like there needs to
be more consistent and i get it it's
subjective from person to person but
bugs ain't subjected right
and i just feel like some people on some
games like and i'm not even say some
people like people in general like to
highlight games when there's massive
bugs because they like the game
right it's but when it comes to other
games they're like oh you know it's okay
it is
and i i just personally feel like when
it comes to scenarios like that
i don't get it
it is what it and i i love the game but
at the end of the day i still stated
that they were bugs
no we get it we get it i mean yeah i'll
jump in because i have the least
experience here of all of everyone and i
barely played it and she wanted to test
it i didn't play it at all
it's salute to you
because i know it's not coming but i
will say you know the parkour
felt amazing you know it really played
where i feel like
the thing the only issue i had was
wasn't i didn't count it and go long
after it kind of bugs but i wasn't too
thrilled about the
performance look
like because i'm a performance guy so i
want to do 60 and do the thing so i
didn't feel it was like within it like
it's like 1080p 1080s yeah and then they
have a 4k 30 they have a quality mode
and they have a 4k mode like one is like
4k i mean one's like well racist right
now
it's like yeah a weird number or
whatever and my my whole thing was i
didn't feel like it but again the
gameplay felt fun you know big open
world the parkour is just on another
level and then you got the zombie aspect
the co-op aspect i want to give them a
shout out to on benji sales he said they
had their highest concurrent peak of any
zombie game ever on steam right now by
far over like 270 000 right now and um
yeah look it's i will say it's one of
those things where it's what you know
you got the the review and then you have
the gamer review kind of thing the gamer
score whatever
i guess the reason that i vocally speak
when it comes to the review system yeah
is i feel like if we never talk about it
it's never going to change but the
reality is the system is what the system
is and and it is and i get that but
nothing changes in life until it's
critical
you have every right to criticize all
i'm saying is from the emotionality
standpoint i don't get myself worked up
about someone's review i don't really
care about i'm going i'm going to speak
about it until now i understand that all
i'm saying is i'm going to the people i
feel are like the genre or i have a
passion for the genre and i'm going to
go to them like you and certain people
because there's certain people you know
i like where i agree with you there are
certain people who i feel
don't understand live service games
don't really play them so they don't
they're not going to have the knowledge
or the information that i'm seeking and
certain things and turn-based or
whatever they're just looking at it as
some regular game and they don't have
that passion i'm going to go for people
for that passion but that's all i got
anything everybody got anything else
before we get to the main event
of this
yeah
i've heard so this is i think with that
the first one people love it's amazing
really
so apart from the actual parkour i heard
that it's kind of a downgrade in a lot
of ways the parkour is improved and it
feels much better because i in the first
one sometimes you call that's a little
bit of a difference or something
so i mean
to me those are all sort of legitimate
sort of takes on this game what real
quick
all the stuff around the marketing for
this game was about
how your choices really affect the world
that it really don't you know it does
not at all
see i see i i would i would give him
flack for that as well i would give if i
was ruining the game i'd give him flack
for that you know what i mean it's like
okay you're not giving me what you said
you were giving me it's not quite there
so
you know what's crazy
real quick you know that part in in the
trailer which show uh with the gameplay
thing where it shows the dude like
flying into the into the the minivan and
he like kidnaps him and he says take me
to yolita yeah like the funny thing is
that don't exist yeah i heard that
really yeah there's some things that
were cut they were definitely cut i mean
so it's like if it's not again you have
to set aside expectation and just focus
on the game that's in front of you right
but when you've been marketing this game
for years as oh my god when you see the
changes that your your your choices make
to this world and it's not really there
i could see the review reflecting that
and and
i can totally and i totally understand
that but when you don't bring it up at
all like for the most part i never if
someone wants to say look this is a good
game had a lot of bugs but i felt like
they didn't improve on the dying light
formula that's fair
but when you don't say it i just have to
take it for face value
because i honestly felt like they didn't
improve like the night time of the game
that much at all like because i feel
like it's low-key easy like you get to
the rooftop ain't nothing really gonna
mess with you up there and if you
initiate a chase you run to a uav light
that's like 10 me 10 feet away you fine
like
but then you got jansen that we was in a
party with yesterday like panicking
every five seconds at night so maybe
it's just me like
so look that's all i got and if we're
going to move on to the main event
unless we oh yeah let's do this
uh we got a couple yeah let's do that
let's do that real quick
uh we got
[Laughter]
like you guys
jetzer five dollars i have over 15 hours
in on pc and haven't had any bugs is
that because it's patched now no co-op
though yeah that co-op is not exciting
it's just really gimmicky
and what's funny is the car didn't even
work during the review process like at
all
yeah oh wow they just probably didn't
want y'all to break the game
which i can respect that if they know
it's not going to work then don't enable
it once i knew that that game was
available for the last generation i knew
for a fact that this game wasn't going
to live up to the expectations cut off
the old generation and then they maybe
you can get that
and get to the guy
moving on
all right we have shout out to daniel
member for 20 months thank you sir we
gotta reviewers can't assume some bugs
will be fixed day one or soon after in
their scores
yeah that's another thing like with day
one patches this day and age are like
yeah who
we gotta read this is violet right there
oh is it a super chat oh yeah oh yeah i
see i did okay yeah no i'll get that
i'll get to that yeah you get today
uh we have the wise old gamer two dollar
super chat king is the heater in your
house not working nope
nope nope it's not because if i put that
boil on right now
at no point in time will you be able to
hear me because it's right
here on the opposite side of the wall
but at the same time you get a chance to
see this uh see that 500 600 mark that
i'm rocking how about that feels good no
good enough sit down and be
be a mess good quiet
uh that we have alex escarza member for
six months i believe cyberpunk changed
the game when it came to bugs in reviews
so i appreciate it for the day one
purchases but i still enjoy the game so
far
that game does not come out till march
april for us king
something like that whenever that game
comes out
have we got heart getting to the five
dollars
it's only confirmed king's prediction is
sony about to go multi-plat will they be
putting more than the show and destiny
on xbox will there be a ps6
nope
in the bushes
what's gonna happen
i know it's a long time for now but i i
want to be around when that piano
because i know that's the one thing king
is not getting right
and the wildest thing is you're going to
sit there and be with your face you're
going to have to you want to do a bend
the knee on that we it's eight
i've collected your knees so many times
i'm up to you that's fine when i have
the colossal of knees on the in in the
back from here telling me what are you
you can have green that you keep
regrowing these knees
[Laughter]
out of control i took the original knees
you know what the thing is what these
dudes don't understand i don't care he'd
go right back
he don't
[Laughter]
there we have the wise old gamer once
again two dollar super chat you can't
compare uh cyberpunk to uh to dynalite 2
cyberpunk is still in beta oh my god wow
wow
then we have a dragon heart yobe yobe tv
remember for six months thank you sir oh
and he's the lord goals i'll put the
question in the chat first first first i
i was supposed to give a shout out to
dragon um dragon heart yobe
yo that's my dude you know what you did
god bless thank you so much um please go
follow him uh on twitter go to his
twitter uh you know follow him
uh a supreme
good dude with a great heart with a good
message
always always that's what's up salute
and we have one away dragons tv five
dollar super chat when we was young we
played through bugs games with no patch
lumen we handled it suck it up stop
whining shout out to crybaby nation man
up people fact [ __ ] blessings but you
know something um
dragon went away
they shipped the games
it was it was either okay
they were completely done
and we didn't have those issues because
they couldn't patch them up and finish
them later and mayamato says that a
broken game is broken forever you
understand there's no going back to it
so you get it right the first time and
if it's a bad game that's that's what we
had to deal with back then we would get
a bad game yeah you would stop with it
now no patch back then you look at that
hot cover are you like yeah this is it
you get it in the house
oh it's slipping with the car
54.95
then we got 108 dragons once again two
dollar super chat shout out to my
brothers old school gamers roll yes yes
sir so yeah brother went away and from
the beginning see you in packs yes sir
uh-oh here we go we got i got my mans
right here
man dingo mcficken
two dollar super chat did someone say
hard
right right as i entered two paul for
the big part wow
[Music]
she was like she was like hold up who's
this man
[Music]
are you supposed to be saying that
game
time
we have nc ghost of lord five dollars in
the chat all the way from low road in
north carolina
virginia i had to show some love to the
lords on the lord's day keep doing what
you do yeah
once again remember for eight months
thank you sir hashtag peace love life to
you all proud to support you guys are
the modern day legends transforming into
icons thank you brother authenticity
from the heart iops hustle is on point
they can sell a universe a new galaxy
man much love much love how are we doing
all right yeah i was like because this
jumps me you know how it does no doubt
we'll do it yeah we got food we got 800
in the chat let's get them likes up
let's get them all right what's up
you know
just real quick where we start that uh
the next topic i uh so i've been playing
overcooked two a lot i actually didn't
realize how much like of a co-op game
that game really is and i really think
that's something we need we need to do
it i love that game
okay
yeah 108 once again five dollar super
chat message to my boy king we ain't
going to act like those reported numbers
for sony ps5 sales is 11.5 million
here we go
you know
keep st keep starting g on these frauds
facts
at the end of the day like i gotta agree
with whatever king going to say about
that like that's not that high can
they're not that much of a difference
considering the generation that xbox had
last generation you would think it's a
lot more different than it is
well both of them is at a shortage so it
is what it is
captain chats uh with the four pound 49
pence super chat better off just holding
off for games these days you'll get a
finish unbroken game and at a cheaper
price paying for unfinished is a no-no
okay yeah unfortunately i don't have
that kind of
structure i don't have that kind of a
will that will about i really don't
it's like i'm part of the problem i
definitely am part of the problem you
you're you're a reviewer so it doesn't
matter yeah i mean you're gonna be
your job is to be overly critical
i feel i still should have more uh
more more willpower than i have
shout out to phil dominus maximus really
expensive for making my willpower a
whole lot
we got flame two dollar super chat
atlanta dying light two had co-op at
launch god bless absolutely no doubt all
right then we had to make sure we didn't
jumped here
we're good all right cool and now shout
out to pragmatic eagle he got that
classic t got that phil dominance
maximus the original og one salute you
already know so let's get into this man
that's what they've been waiting for and
so i would say
yeah bungie to join the place
close to us
family yes join the playstation shout
out to lord jim ryan president and ceo
we are thrilled to announce that sony
air interactive entertainment has
entered into an agreement to acquire
bungie which will bring one of the
world's greatest development studios
into the playstation family bungie has
created two of gaming's most iconic
franchises halo and destiny and with
their deep expertise of bringing
immersive experiences at great scale to
the community he goes on to say it's
that expertise coupled with a highly
engaged playstation community that makes
this partnership such an incredible
exciting addition he says bungie's track
record multi-platform publishing and
live game services will assist us in
realizing our ambitions to take
playstation beyond the console and
increase our potential audience they
will remain independent and
multi-platform will enjoy creative
freedom and their track record in
developing massively successful
franchises in the sci-fi shooter genre
will be highly complementary to sie owns
ip portfolio then it goes on
bungie had definitely released the
statement themselves desti 2 our shared
vision and they said if you share our
vision for destiny a single global
community you can play anywhere on any
device join us we are just getting
started so they had three major key
points in their vision and it says one
community multi-platform destiny 2 will
stay on all current platforms expand to
new play and expand to new platforms 2.
self-publish creatively independent
bungie maintains full creative control
and publishing independence of the
destiny universe and three same game
everywhere every player should have an
amazing destiny experience no matter
where you play the last couple things i
will say is that they talked about you
know will destiny 2 witch queen include
any platform excuses are exclusive they
say no they talk about um obviously the
creative independence again they talk
about the commitment to multi-platform
games they talk about cross-platform
features will they be changed to remove
as far as crossplay and all that they
say no now another question towards the
end they say bungie has future games in
development will they now become
playstation exclusives no we want the
worlds we are creating to extend to
everywhere people play games we will
continue to be and they stress this this
is throughout the theme self-published
creatively independent and will continue
to drive one unified bungie community
the only answer they question that they
answered yes to was i play dusty on
steam xbox or stadia will my platform
still be supported they answer yes king
the floor is yours the hottest subject
iop foundation game minus off
destiny and bungie sony acquisito what
are your thoughts sir
the master plan is all coming to
fruition okay let's get it you know jim
ryan told you his ambitions
is beyond the console
it's all in the words
the dna
of bungie is multi-plat now
games as a service
this is what he's done is king he said
any device
and the best part about that whole thing
is when and this is where i gather y'all
all your needs together and put it into
one big box cause i got one giant
guillotine
that's gonna chop off all yo is a
playstation six coming this is not it's
not
because he's showing you they're living
outside of the box
outside they're going game okay at the
same time they also told you 25 games is
in development 10 of those games is
games of service
they're using
bungie
with their expertise
in global gaming
linking these games on every device
outside of this wall garden that old
sony cared about jim ryan doesn't care
about that the board doesn't care about
that you guys are not enough
so when they say that understand what he
actually means
it was a time where they tested
playstation now or playstation plus
inside their televisions you remember
that and all you needed was your
controller
they do have the technology that they're
able to put that app inside their
televisions partnerships
deals
we know
now that bungie and microsoft talk first
right
microsoft wasn't with that you for the
streets crap
so you think that was the
hold up
at no point no i at no point in time am
i marrying some chick we having this big
wedding and i'm going out there and
putting out a big promo and all this and
you still dating the old dudes that you
were
that is not a goal that is not a thing
so they sat there and it was like yo so
what we want in this whole thing is
we want the money
we want our independence
we want to come and go as we choose
and you can't say a thing about it
and uh and all our future endeavors is
for the streets
you can't say nothing at what level of
desperation are you at that you agreed
at what point in time do you say to
yourself this is a good idea for me
unless
you for the streets
be the only time you say oh your girl
can go on a a cruise with her friends
because you're going on a vegas cruise
with yoga
so one wait
a cruise
wow she for the streets
you for the street
you understand
no point in time you can't it's your
boat for the streets
this is the height of the most open
relationship contract i've ever seen all
only thing that transferred here was
money and then when you look at the
contract they gave some money so you
can't leave
so uh
clarify are you implying that um
that
sony's a pimp and
[Applause]
so how do you kick how do you
internalize that portion of this deal
that um not even allegedly that it came
out as far as the what is it 3.6 billion
yeah that there's a portion of it for
retainership and keeping you can't go no
place
you
i'm giving extra money to keep you here
that's like your girl telling you i
don't care what you do just come back
home
what the hell is this i've i've never
seen this in no contract yo
and this is the problem
y'all thought you see
and this is the thing
y'all thought it was gonna be a bethesda
situation
i saw goofy dudes running
and you know that's where they act with
it because their brain said the same
thing
yo at no point in time i don't i don't
see i don't i literally don't see this
as good unless
your main goal
is to be
everywhere
don't front like bungie's community
isn't one of the best communities don't
front like the way they reach each and
every
group
doesn't feel unified
on steam on playstation on xbox it all
feels like one place right so
sony sees that
that's in their dna
this is excuse me
sony's ambitions
with their games of service
to grow beyond this ceiling that they
put on their head
they cannot grow past that whatever a
number
and let's say 120 million is the the
ceiling for consoles right in their life
cycle they can't grow past that number
well because at an artificial ceiling
that they put above their head to give
you your flowers and we gotta let it go
again because he's still got his hand up
i don't know if he got his balls but
there you go the thing is
this is i'll give you your flowers in
this respect you know you've been on
your soapbox as far as as much as i love
hashtag just one right you've always
been on your soapbox like yo not enough
right yeah all these bangers so to speak
that you know the third you know those
third person cinematic great narrative
story games but you've always said you
know that doesn't represent the entire
base buying those games and the live now
with this live service thing do you
think this is where they ultimately want
to go because they want that engagement
they want those type of games to kind of
go past where they currently that that
lane that they currently reside in
you know the biggest problem with sony
and we always said it is because they
didn't have any first person shooting
games that had of any note and any
multiplayer games and with this one deal
they they crossed all that right yeah so
then this is where that level of
desperation was
they saw the generation uh the
degenerated revenue
from whatever bungie was making what is
that 200 million a year after
you know um
and i think it's probably a quarter or
something like that i forget but they
they generate enough income and enough
traffic
that engagement yeah yeah it's it's
there and it's always there every time
they drop a dlc you know what the dlc is
everybody comes back during this longest
drought
and it being out of game pass and it's
still been at least on the xbox side
it's been the top 10 most games played
and hardcore players considered this a
drought because witch queen got delayed
and it was still really no major
activities to do besides like the 30th
anniversary kind of stuff so it is
interesting that they've kind of this is
definitely a drought yeah they fought
they've kind of figured out the console
live service mmo space regardless of how
anyone feels about destiny may not like
the game but the engagement has shown
that this is a ravenous base and i was
shocked out of game pass it still was
doing that so they must be doing well
you know as far as you know i mean
totally clearly those type of numbers
whatever but
yeah i want to open up the attic has
been patient you know you guys still got
your head up but i want to make sure you
get your balls off this rocked the
nation you uh you gave me that call
while i was at work i was in meetings i
couldn't answer i was like something i
got to take this call from addict cause
i knew it had to be important he's like
yo
they bought punchy what's going on so
now that the dust has settled that's the
two one of your favorite games in this
relationship how are you feeling about
this acquisition about sony
i'm actually glad it happened um
still i feel like they're still
br uh i still don't know the intentions
with bungie with sony but um i do feel
like
because of project matter i think that's
what it's called in it project yeah the
one uh the legend uh hero shooter game
yeah i do think that
if that game takes off
after
the uh
that big expansion they're doing in 2024
that might be it for destiny uh so i
feel a little more confident now because
now they are backed by a bigger company
yeah so you know because here's the
thing like regardless
what
down the line sony is uh regardless what
they do in the future one thing they're
always going to need is multiplayer
games because they don't really have any
yeah so i don't feel like sony and
playstation would let destiny die
you know let's say project matter or
whatever that is starts doing really
good
and they're like look we don't have
enough funds we're not enough people to
maintain two games at once playstation
most likely to be like what you need
because in my opinion
if they were still independent and there
was that choice they would let destiny
die off because it's been so long and
they want to they want to focus on their
new game that's if it took off if like
project matter came out and it was mid
no one was playing it then you know
maybe they would uh gravitate back
towards destiny kind of like how you saw
with um gta 5 and red dead redemption 2
online right like they tried red dead
redemption 2 online and they realized
that that wasn't giving them the same
results that they got with gta 5 so they
kind of dropped red dead online a little
bit went back to gta 5. uh but i i'm
still a little you know me and carl go
back and forth on whether or not the
future of bungie on xbox platform i
still think it's up in the air
uh that's just my personal opinion on it
because i
think that you know regardless what was
said what like because when you was
reading all that stuff all i heard on
there is them not directly answering
questions like is it going to play a
multi question
yeah
is this going to be a multiplayer uh is
this good they didn't bring xbox up at
all no i just like rival consoles
so there's only two rival consoles
that's interesting
and i get that yeah but i just need to
see addict needs to see no no no you
know why i don't like that i don't like
that because and this is no attack to
you
this is this is literally an attack on
every person that i hear say that same
rhetoric on twitter
how much forward does jim have to be
he literally put rival consoles it is
the first bullet point too yeah it's
weird in the press release over there
i've never heard that from somebody else
so i mean you can take that as the
gospel right there but i know you don't
trust jim now because jim also told you
he believed in generations
you know this is true honest as
primarily xbox playing destiny players
we've gone through it right we've gone
this rule
i know i know but it's just historically
i understand where he's coming from
because historically
you got the bungie aspect with exclusive
exotics being playstation hawkmoon
exclusive crucible maps excluding
strikes and then hold on and then
coupled with sony's history historically
of when they acquire something
you ain't getting it right so i
understand that trepidation
bungie was owned by
activists
they went and dropped a bag at
activision to get exclusive content
this is not the same thing yeah well so
somebody paid for
the um extension marketing marketing and
they were basically a year
exactly
secretly extended their um what you call
it
get it get it get it get it get your
ball
here's my thing with these like if you
look at stuff like this um
they say will destiny to the witch queen
include any exclusive uh any uh platform
exclusives why didn't they say well
destiny 2 ever or anything that's
related to not after the 22nd of this
month right like it's just like
even if this took in place i don't like
i highly doubt something like that would
have because it was but purchased so
close to the witch queen why are we
bringing up the witch queen that's in
for like two weeks yeah because the
witch queen is the most relevant thing
but i understand but i get that but my
point is like it's just like oh
i'm not saying i don't think they're
going to do nothing with destiny my
thing's more like you're more things
like matter like moving forward and
let's say that you know right now
bungie is strictly we're not doing a
destiny three right uh but
you know the the way playstation's moved
in the past does it make me bullishly
things it's like yo we know right we got
destiny 2 and all these platforms how
much money is going to cost to make a
destiny 3 so we can make that exclusive
like you know it's just like just
because they've came out
just because they've come out openly and
they've said
we could self-publish does not mean in
my opinion that they haven't had some
verbal agreement behind closed doors
when this is all done because i keep in
mind this isn't even done yet like right
like
and you have to keep in mind too that
they might have these claws to get out
of it if they want to get out of it yes
that is if stuff goes south they're
getting out like they they're the bad
domestic wife they're getting out now
they've been through two marriages it's
what went horrible they want those claws
they want that money also in the in the
same token how they can't give they
can't confirm all it's because the deal
is also hasn't done so they can't tell
you
the final shape everything the deal
still hasn't done so it works on both
sides that the deal isn't done that he
can't tell you everything also but i
understand your trepidation i really do
i'm not trying to minimize what your
point i do want to get solved getting
bars off because he's been patient
or now
[Laughter]
all right so
surface level for me
as soon as i heard it you guys saw what
i put in our in our private chat i was
like
they fixed the deficiency that they they
needed to address
on the surface level getting destiny and
associating the destiny name and brand
with playstation even though it's going
to live everywhere is big for them
they're going to get that destiny back
the association's going to be there
it's what they needed they had nothing
else like that whatsoever great on a
surface level
now on the playstation side and what
this means for playstation and how
the playstation sort of ecosystem and
and ethos of
operating changes
i think in a lot of ways this is how
they shore up
their ability to continue being the
playstation that people expect them to
be means meaning making those big super
expensive
aaa prestige games that people expect
from them right i always go back to what
sean layton said about this is
unsustainable right and he meant
unsustainable in the current way that
sony operates correct right they had no
other forms of income they have ps plus
coming in they have whatever they had
coming in from ps now but at the end of
the day that income coming in was never
going to be enough to support
the next generation of uncharteds and
last of us that are going to cost you
200 million dollars to make and it'll
probably cost you
you know take you upwards of five years
to make each time right it's gonna be
super expensive
what this does now jumping into the
service based games all of a sudden
i i think there's a bit of this is why
you don't listen to jim ryan right jim
ryan is a dude that's going to say he's
going to tell you exactly what he thinks
he wants you to you want to hear
but the educated gamer when i hear 10
service based games i'm like bruh you'll
be lucky if one of those works
if one of those actually gets a
community and and it's successfully
successful right right so
at the end of the day though i think he
has the right idea we they need to
create different streams of revenue for
the playstation ecosystem for them to
continue to be able to provide those
other games without missing a beat right
and for me that is big and to me that
speaks to
a change in philosophy yeah and now they
have this two-prong approach
there's a two-prong approach now there
is the service based games that i tell
you right now anything that is service
based coming out of playstation studios
would be bungie anybody else that is
going to be fully cross platform on
everything under the sun because it
makes sense
yeah real quick question do you think
that
because i think xbox could do it because
xbox has a lot of experience when it
comes to games to service
do you think playstation's
infrastructure can handle 10 games as a
service like no nobody that's that's
that's that's why when jim said that i
laughed i was like really jim they
should have told you to shut up because
you don't know what you're talking about
you're just trying to sound good but but
anybody anybody who if anybody's in the
position to make a quality game sure
playstation right when you think about
the fact that the biggest game on the
planet right fortnite
epic gave up its other games to work on
fortnite because they knew the amount of
work and dedication it needed pubg one
game warzone it's a it's a whole
separate thing they got three studios
exactly so to think that you're going to
put out a whole bunch of service based
games no matter how different they are
right hopefully they're very different
you're not going to find the crowds that
you need to support them over a long
period of time
for most of them most of them are going
to fail it's just it's just it's just
the math of it that most of them are
going to be like what
forecasting in a sense i got you know
sure sure what you want to do and then
what realistically actually realistic is
going to happen right and that's the
thing when he said that he makes it seem
like yeah we're gonna rule the world
with these 10 games and in the back of
my mind i'm like no that's not happening
like that's not take it that way i just
took it like a a directional shift like
a philosophy shift like we should have
but he wanted to excite people with that
right and then for me as a person in the
know i'm like nah you're scaring me with
that you said what a hardcore was scary
or insight so
to me in my mind you're just
overreaching again and and i can't
believe what you're saying just like i
believe in generations i can't believe
what you're saying addict and then back
this off
well kate had his hand first i i just
see what if he takes naughty dog and
everybody and just say you know what
oh y'all stop working on what you're
working on
because attic had a point wars only got
three studios working all right what if
they like you know everybody work all
these guys
playstation videos
here's the thing here's the thing about
what came from
here's the thing with kings saying
right now i wouldn't say they do it but
let's say they do this in three or four
of these are taking off and they getting
real good money
is if you got these single-player games
they're making good money but you
launched these games as a service and
three or four of them are taking off and
they're making really good money with
these micro transactions and stuff you
know anyone in in a position of
leadership will be said
for sure you stupid i'm not saying that
they would ever do that they would
probably outsource and make something
else to help that studio but all i'm
saying is that these services that are
taking off kicking then the next
fortnight so et cetera et cetera they're
making all this money and but they're
falling behind on concept but you got
these these other studios are that they
make money but not this time right that
jim's gonna prioritize the money he's
like okay who's not working over there
at saint monica cuz you're working over
here right now that's right but but that
that's what they all do i just said
fortnight they killed the other game
because now we we're working on fortnite
and that's it so that's what they that's
guaranteed that's what's gonna happen
but when you say 10 games i'm thinking
the reality is two maybe
two that actually work right and
are going to be successful so if you got
to consider what they're talking about
games and servers like it's not like 10
fresh games as a service grant trisble
is technically a game
they're making it's like
they do
the show's probably technically a games
we talked about that last year yes
factions is already included in that
right factions
let's go
in since we're probably really
realistically two to three more new
games right
she was like what day's going to that
being kind of stopped for the remake
thing and
look there's trouble yeah ben's studio
they they helping the of service i can
always guarantee you at this point
it's going to get to the point in the
death cycle where they're like yo
tell ben's studio that uh that that
games as a service three needs their
help we'll let them work on these stuff
a couple months yeah i really think
y'all really think
he's gonna just go that route and but
see
it it is it is boisterous to say 10.
somebody who doesn't know what they're
talking about would say like that's what
makes it
here's the thing song it's just like you
said
these games
it's just like this that's where he went
got bungie he doesn't know
it's just like you said these games as a
service they're not easy to make they
need a lot of manpower
and then when you're sitting there
stressing on the manpower you have crazy
amounts of
of of contractors working and you're
still not getting to that point where
you feel like you need to you're going
to start pulling for the resources that
you feel like you can do without well
he's already started pulling from the
bench
you're going to start pulling from the
people that's working at naughty dog
that's not doing anything right now
because obviously
when you're working on these games
you've got sectors some sectors aren't
really doing things that other sectors
are so if some people at naughty dog's
not currently working right now because
they've already done their job they're
going to pull them like yo remote access
and help these people while you're
working on yours right yes while they're
working on yourself so okay finish your
boss off then i got to get off so okay
so
so yeah
guys yeah i feel the change is gonna is
all the way left is good i don't think
it's like i'm saying that there is a
road that goes there oh yeah there's
definitely a road that can go there if
it does that
before before i go to the bungee side of
it it's interesting it's very
interesting that i didn't hear
like it's i didn't hear the playstation
nation and uproar
at all like they were so
no it was so it was like it felt like it
was they were so happy that there was a
quote-unquote response to activision
blizzard right they didn't pay attention
to the stuff that literally
threatens everything that is playstation
up into the room
like nobody addressed it nobody was like
oh my god wait a minute 10 games they
laughed it off like i did like this is
stupid but at the same time if this man
is genuinely
going down this path the culture of what
playstation is to now is very much in
jeopardy right so
it was interesting to me that nobody
really spoke about that i'm sure
probably somebody like colin or whatever
so that that was weird to me right so
to me
obviously what we know as playstation
and what they do today is going to
evolve and change considerably over the
next five years that's for sure
um it's on the bungee side on the bungee
side
look man more power to you yeah you you
get what you could get and obviously you
negotiated
the negotiation game
on the attic show we were saying
shout out to bungie for not finessing
one but two giant billionaire
corporation
three three three no actually four
because they finessed apple in the
beginning microsoft came and raised that
baby then they got activision and now
they got sony stadium they got the
technology
and they're just saying we're going our
separate ways yeah so i'm i'm completely
confident in them in what they plan to
do in the gaming space right everything
they plan to do continue with destiny
destiny i i guess at least has another
two to three years on its life cycle
according to them yeah um and then
whatever the next game is right
so i'm confident in that i know that
they they're going to knock that out the
park
what's worrisome to me is this
what i feel talk about it
this delusion that destiny and again i i
need to ask you i will ask you guys
objectively yes but be respectful i just
is destiny to
of the caliber mm-hmm if you're
respectful you haven't been playing
of a star wars
of uh star trek is the lore and the
characters by far that deep that deep
wait a minute the lord the lord's fire
though i know you have a plan yeah you
know what's crazy
there is factions like the cabal well we
don't know [ __ ] about it i'm looking i'm
never going to say oh it's better than
stop i'm not going there but i'm not
saying i'd say it's all the same
all i will say is that the narrative
team
since i would say for a second and they
switched to uh um seasonal format the
positive of the seasonal format has been
these amazing stories that kind of
transition from season to season and
you're involving multiple characters and
multiple things going on at one time and
it's becoming into this deeper universe
they've really done a good job like the
story is in the best place it's ever
been the issue has just been the amount
of new content weapons maps clean up
anti-cheat things modes that just need
help and it's
the gameplay is always solid yeah the
problem is the base heats up the concept
we're gonna get this the base eats up
the cotton they'll go with this super
yellow to see if the chat says wow oh
the base eats up the content and the
problem is they're not able to produce
enough content at a fast pace yeah to
satiate it that's the problem when it
comes to the story though they've
they've got it they got shout out to
them so shout out to them again for
getting that bag because again going i
guess
they were able to do what they wanted to
do when they were independent but they
realized that they couldn't release it
the cadence that they could that they
wanted to right
you you tag on covet on top of that it
makes it even more complicated so again
shout out to them for getting that bag
and understanding that and being able to
negotiate that right
if they can pull this off and turn this
into the next star wars i will bend the
knee um so they got that those times so
entertainment yeah i will i will just
end with this seeing their trajectory
and what they're doing right now
i i think i'm respectfully saying
goodbye to bungie forever oh my god i
don't think they're making games for me
for you know you you're with ryan yeah
ryan grew up with them and he's like i
love you for making halo but i don't
like this live service stuff but i feel
good and then
i don't think that for me anymore okay i
personally
don't see like
have they confirmed they're trying to do
this tv stuff yes do you want me to read
the statement yeah because like
what are they like are they gonna like
i just like i guess realistically you
can make stuff but like my mindsets like
what direction are they going to go like
yeah back in 2016
you know would be cool if they were
right here we go meanwhile
philosophically this is jim this isn't
about pulling things into the
playstation world this is about building
huge and wonderful new worlds together
meanwhile on the bungie star pete pete
parsons tells games industry.biz that
sony offers the ability to accelerate
its own plans which include the prospect
of taking its ip to new entertainment
mediums such as tv and filming the bar i
want to get off with it
to conclude i mean to link in with this
is we got to read that free all right i
got you three i got you guys
remember the director of destiny luke
smith and mark noseworthy right those
were the pers kind of surveyors of the
game they have now been elevated into a
new role they are literally now the
surveyors of like the creative universe
the overall destiny almost like kevin
feige mcu equivalent where they want to
take the destiny ip and these characters
of this law into different mediums and
movie and tv is definitely when they
were to go and we have to admit you know
sony as far as you got the uncharted
thing out right now you bungee see that
you know what i'm saying you see let's
be real even though i know people like
yo marvel have more to do with the
spider-man thing but spider-man no wayne
holmes out there you know what i'm
saying what are they they see that and
ideally they want to get the destiny ip
that's how they envision whether or not
it's going to be successful or not
that's another thing and you see
obviously what's going on with halo the
series and all that stuff but continue
my very last thing is
um
how does this sort of two-prong approach
now a new direction right what does that
m in your mind what does how does that
make spartacus look what what does that
do for spartacus because i think once
again like i said before the two-prong
approach now allows them
really close
they're gonna hold those prestige titles
i think we're talking about the you know
those prestige triple a games coming up
coming i don't think that happens
anymore because you have this well this
is what i say and i'll jump in now
because like my thing is
with see addicts representation i get it
but i think this is the real thing
where
other platforms need to be concerned so
i think everyone i think the games are
going to go everywhere that's just me
personally until you know we see
something suspect and you know
saying you're living off
but i'm talking about is it going to be
the service based games that are going
to be everywhere or do you think
because of the amount of service based
games that he wants to put out there
right that means that those aaa
single-player games aren't going to be
out there i mean that's the question i
don't know about whether they went
that's how fast they would accelerate
day to day but what i do think i do
think the days of destiny and game pass
is rap
i think that's a wrap because they're
going to have their live service when it
drops and you best believe in my opinion
that destiny will be in there right
there they'll be like okay xbox guys
you're gonna pay the 70 or whatever it
is and you go pay the expansions and
destiny if you want to experience the
content i do think spartacus is the play
because at the end of the day you have
to have a diverse portfolio as much as i
love hashtag just one you can't launch a
live service and it's all hashtag just
one games it's like netflix and it's all
just documentaries like you can't do
that you got to have different types of
genre so people could go to the service
let's get into this now this is a big
one when i first heard the news i was
kind of like adding i ain't gonna lie
the fan there was a slight fanboy of me
that took me to a dark time where there
was those playstation exclusives and
xbox fans never saw hawkmoon in its
original form and the borealis exotic
and i was like oh no they about to do
because i'm thinking the old school sony
and bungie may be taking a bag right so
then as the dust settle you start to
read the news you're like wait a minute
the first bullet point and shout out the
whole globe we had or defrauded
ultimately i duke i'm telling y'all
right now you have a list hope broke
this thing down like no other like the
thing that when you put out these
statements right you all you both come
together you have these ideas of what
you want to do and things that you
prioritize that are important to you for
the relationship but it's still the work
as king said the first bullet point is
not about anything else but we it's like
defensive we're going to be independent
y'all just let you know everything's
multiplied we haven't changed what we're
doing right so which is very strange
right especially based on sony's history
when they do acquire you don't really
see it and then for the sony side i get
it that's a deficiency it's a smart move
sure up your definition i'm with sob
shore up what you don't do well i i was
going to get it was funny as pride of
this deal i was going to start getting
on them this year because as much as i
give xbox crap what hashtag just won i
was gonna be like yo where's hashtag
just2 y'all first party
yes we've been on we've been on it their
first party has not been making
multi-player live service game i come
from a sony with so calm killzone where
these joints at right so what has
happened is they've gotten into a
complacency
you know where they're at
they're not enough oh well you said well
with that too but let me see if there's
a ball so the thing is where i looked at
the deficiency how they were trying to
solve it it's like hey we'll throw the
bag at call of duty for this marketing
deal and how to satiate that base so
they're basically paying for these other
things to fill in their weaknesses but
let's be real again shout out to hulk
we're not these deals are done four to
five months in advance right we know
that but we can't say that the microsoft
activision acquisition if there were any
hold-ups to getting the deal done and
maybe bungie was like yo 3.6 or
somebody's like yeah maybe three you
know saying maybe 2.5 you know whatever
and and budgie's like hey well maybe you
know we want this exclusive one our
titles to still go away like yeah we
don't know then that deal happens
there could be a scenario again
speculation where they go whoa whoa wait
let's get back to the table real quick
it's 3.6 and then okay because at the
end of the day we have to admit
the way microsoft moves we still i
firmly i i still have the mindset that
call of duty might still be exclusive
and not muzzled but
we can't assume if sony can't play the
assumed game either we see what happened
to bethesda right so they in their mind
like wow the thing that we were banking
on with call of duty being on could be
gone and if we don't have live service
addressed
this is a major problem so i could
totally see that scenario of that at
least finalizing it when getting it over
the hump if there was any little things
now back to the bungee thing all right
yeah this is what it listen if you love
destiny this is one of the wildest
situations this this this this studio
this company i've never seen anything
like this in game that's why i love
being a fan like what they've been
through is crazy all right so to me
that's how i look at it
microsoft situation with them in the
beginning
they learned the value of ownership
if you don't own your ip someone can do
whatever they want with it and you're
just gonna have to get in there and pump
out them halos right so that was first
they lost right
i was like oh we can't get a rise too
yeah three four three we need another
halo so now they were able magically to
get out of these they are the master
magicians of escaping they're the
houdinis of getting out of something
right so you get that
oh yeah just crazy crazy prenup game is
crazy so get out the job
now active vision come on yo will we'll
take that but then they realize okay
release cadence you are beholden to this
call of duty every biannual remember
destiny comet addict comet got remember
i lost podcast is named after the dlc
rise of lion right rise of iron when it
came out wasn't supposed to be right it
was supposed to be destiny 2 then
activision wanted it then and bungie was
like yo we can't produce at this pace
then you have the the big public fallout
when activision and board meet and say
yo
we are we didn't like the sales before
say we it disappointed it it did not
meet expectation then you got luke smith
coming out publicly against activision
oh we don't feel that way we we firmly
believe in our product that this is an
amazing game so now you start to see the
fracture then they able to get out in
this unprecedented deal where activation
goes away
okay
no no no i just said they they said bye
yeah and get out the deal we're like how
did this ha and they keep ownership like
what is going on tina turner right
now
yeah
they wound up in game pass oh yeah they
get they get the game passed it but i
will say this which you know that's
probably the reason we didn't get game
uh we didn't get witch queen in game
pass because they knew they were going
to yeah yes
so here's the thing but this is where i
got to take the l because in my opinion
look we know phil loves destiny
phil is hardcore destiny this hit us
hard i can't imagine how it hit him
right so
even though i'm with jess gordon even
though back in the day pauses like oh we
weren't selling or whatever bungee stop
we know they were negotiations and the
rumors were that the money was of this
of equal level if not more to what this
only deal is right so the whole thing is
comes down to the valuation how much
microsoft values them and then also how
much they value themselves and in my
opinion again i'm not in the room but
you can't tell me king
that if the microsoft deal was offered
maybe destiny would stay multi-plat but
you damn sure i don't think matter and
all their future ips according to how
microsoft has been moving with
acquisitions those games were going to
have to be exclusive to game pass do you
not agree king or not the wave okay yeah
that's why i put my hand up let's go i
was letting you let's go
yeah i'll i'll go after him
yeah phil wasn't i don't care how much
phil loves him yeah
phil said no no that's why you didn't
know
yeah it was stay inside game pass all
the dlc and stuff will be free blah blah
blah blah blah and uh whatever you
making in the future will be ours yeah
and and that's about and it was like no
exactly and this is this is where the
the cheaper part well you know i think
bungie wanted to keep their independence
and i don't think it was um yes 3.6 it
was less than 3.6 first bullet remember
that's in there is to retain
the um the developers yeah remember sony
went above and beyond to make it happen
to make it happen and again it might be
out of a shout out to key
it might be out of a way of desperation
like you're saying with the call of duty
we already know call of duty ain't going
over there i'm sorry
um we already been in this scary movie
it's called bethesda zenimax deal i'm
with you y'all found out exactly what
the hell is the contract's run up
exactly
it's like that's on the paper yeah
definitely that's how i look at it
the only way it changes is if the
government really goes hard and tries to
make it exactly because
on that list microsoft wasn't there i
feel like i remember microsoft was the
biggest donor yes don't tell another um
be quiet but hey if you're gonna follow
it you don't talk about it talk about it
um
talk back at me
talk to me now
tell this kid i'm talking to you i'm
talking to you talk back to me
you guys are ridiculous
i love you i love you
microsoft was not gonna uh adhere to
that stuff sony did because sony needed
certain things from it but
i believe
they are aligned in their mission
but sony doesn't trust right yeah that's
why that 1.2 billion is in there for the
retainership of the developers because
you're not going to jump shipping
that to me this is expert negotiation on
both sides yeah as far as but greg
i solve i'm sorry okay
that happens that happens in every sort
of acquisition it happens
why what does bungie mean to you with
bungee leaves after you buy them nothing
they don't mean anything like you need
to keep them like
this
no
the number came up and it's a big number
so you know you want to keep damn near
everybody and you know the people at the
top of the uh of the food chain are
going to get the most money right but at
the end of the day this is what you do
when you acquire something like this you
have to keep them also it's nothing to
you
so okay it's a big number yes but this
is happening anyways you say that
standard practice it became it became a
bullet point right yes i feel it okay
let me give a finish because this is
great but the thing is so where we at
now and my whole field diatribe xbox you
know why didn't work and that's why i
think it's the perfect move that they
were able to position with sony because
again
independence means so
much to this company people do not
really they've been through the ringer
and they're going to put out the most
expansive prenup you've ever seen if it
goes left that's just my opinion
bungie's lawyers need a right yes their
lawyer the fact that they were able to
get out the activision deal
straight into a sony deal right and then
here's the thing again i gotta plug the
show find a dude ultimate please hold
law is is a beast
he said the deal is so unprecedented in
the fact that when people get a quiet
let's be real addict like that you're
cool the shareholders meeting is about
to begin
with the shareholders beauty coming
usually the overseers are like yo this
highs going to go you know what i'm
saying
they have structured this deal in such a
way that bungie shareholders cannot be
removed
out of the situation their influence is
final so what hog is saying is this
sony has kind of positioned himself in a
weird way in the sense that you've
you've you've adopted this child
who could now do whatever they want
unlike the rest of playstation game
studios you don't think sony said monica
or sony or all the others want to say
hey we like to put our stuff on other
yeah we like to do what them doing how
come they getting to stay up late at
night at 9pm
but here's the thing
they've set up they've positioned
themselves as an un unequal there are
above as far as the abilities and things
that they can do for
independence his point
where this is where sony i mean bungie
has to be kept sony is going to leverage
them very hard for this multiplayer and
this live stream
and they go exactly so that's how we got
to see how this is going to work long
term not putting negative energy out it
could work but there could be some
things because let's just say
hypothetically bungie says we got
creative control we go multiply we can
do we want to put it on luna we want to
make this weird game on whatever for
only exclusive to whatever it's only you
know so they might feel awake
they have net ease money don't they yeah
right i don't know
and is that was that for like a mobile
game or is that for this next big thing
that's supposed to come that's the part
of the contracts i don't know but i will
say like i said the level of this deal
people have to understand legally this
is unprecedented what they have
negotiated and they have positioned
themselves from a shareholder
standpoint from a creative control
standpoint that if it goes left
they can skate you know what i'm saying
and if it goes as far as creative
control they still could do what they
want but to addict's point i feel his
concern i think for attic where he may
need to see it is when matter that
eventual hero shooter
overwatch cloney type whimsical game
that's coming out for them if that comes
out and he doesn't see xbox's name there
or another platform then i could
understand ada's concern there for sure
and obviously if there is eventual a
destiny for it yeah i think you're wrong
about about the multiplayer games being
everywhere i really do think you're
wrong about okay i think
i think on the microsoft side like the
ultimate goal of game pass is to be
everywhere right right let's say they
can't finagle that everywhere let's say
sony's super resistant to game pass on
there and i would understand why they
would be resistant because the only way
that game pass on playstation makes
sense is if you make playstation
versions of those first party games and
right so that they're comparable right
otherwise it's an inferior version of
game passes
infuriating trailers yeah it's inferior
to the real thing right right
i just think what this sony deal does is
show me anyway that i've that these two
companies for the remainder for for the
foreseeable future
when it comes to multiplayer service
based games are gonna be willing to play
ball with each other because they
understand the need of having both of
those communities i think so i'm in
agreement with you and i think diverse
what do you know because you were saying
that like when phil you know it wasn't
when phil talked to bungie it was like
nah
you know
this is coming to game pass right my
thing is like
i think that discussion when it comes to
a service based game that requires as
big of a community around it as possible
i think microsoft and now sony's
thinking is that we need to work
together and allow these wall gardens to
be opened up
i agree all these games i think i just i
think theo
i think the only reason that microsoft
didn't buy them it wasn't necessarily
that they were going to pull stuff off
playstation or anything like that
we're not going to spend this amount of
money and you control this amount of
your company oh yeah i know yeah i feel
like that level of control control yeah
that that's all you said i'm with you
like think about it right now and i'm
with king we i wouldn't be surprised if
they put cfds on playstation eventually
like
because to me like those type of games
don't make sense to be exclusive we all
agree
those elder scrolls onlines those
you know desties live service and the
war zones
it you look like a bully pulling a
community out of that game you look
crazy it does feel good though i want to
see twitter
no that's the thing because yeah you
guys said that yeah i don't think
whatever the next thing from
that if
the conversation was probably like okay
the next thing from from bungie is going
to be in game pass exclusively but by
opinion that that's about maybe maybe
that one game is where we differ yeah
right because you're you're saying you
think mata would say they wouldn't
because it's a live service because it's
a live stream that's right right my gut
tells me because it doesn't make sense
why this we know it's not about money
with microsoft no no right so so it's
clearly there's some philosophical hold
up as to why this that's not about money
i mean
i would just feel that i would feel a
type of way if i owned you out right
before and now you come back and we're
going to equal footing like i know i
should i would feel away like yeah
that's what i'm saying because at the
end of the day it's like fair we bought
you so you're going to have to do you
know yeah you're going to bend in here
like how elder scrolls and fall out i
mean to be to be fair though there's a
lot of a lot of going around that
uh you know
microsoft a lot of the internal
microsoft they do take a lot of the
blame for what happened with bungie
so for sure
i don't think that it would be one of
those things where it's like you you
know we used to be uh we used to be
married but then you know uh yeah i
ended up divorcing you and now you're
not i'm not now you gotta work with my
new wife
i would say that this is i think their
prenup game is the ellis
i think yeah i think look this is good
this is good i still think he's
literally the only company in history
that can go to multiple companies and
get away skull freaks this is
unprecedented and get a better deal and
get a better deal every time look this
is good for destiny the problem has been
satiating this base you know gambit is
in shambles crucible still needs new
maps there's a rework you know the the
pve the raid component is always good
but the weapons and fusions it's been
slow there's still so much there then
you have like attic made a great point
then they're about to take on a whole
nother game right because people was
always mad at destiny like oh you guys
are making this overwatchy hero shooter
maybe that's how come you ain't been
taking care of trials of osiris and pvp
is it in the show they have nearly a
thousand people in that that that studio
have they um have they ever confirmed
what matter is yeah hero shooter
whimsical
kind of overwhelmed have they confirmed
it has nothing to do with destiny they
have not confirmed that it has nothing
to do with what what happens if
yeah last word we talked about that like
what do you guys feel about that that
whimsical like well humorous like you
know not super serious you know watch is
not like super serious kill em yeah yeah
it's fun you got you know the may and
all that but look i mean if you listen
to shax for five minutes he's that is
literally here he's like he's not being
serious at all look i think it's great i
think like i said they'll have the
resources they need it's great for them
for their ambitions and in the movie
stuff you know sony it's great it's what
you saw it so shows up that need it
really helps them the question though
like you may solve
is you know for the core
sony guys the guys that love the hashtag
just one the guys that love those indie
darling games stuff that we've known
them for your life is in jeopardy i
think i gotta go to that extreme it
could be but i think it's oh i think
it's the obvious all i will say is it is
i am with addict and number sense just
pay attention because jim is really
putting this out with this live service
and that jim likes that money man he
likes services make money he'll change
all right and that's
the core
playstation guy running told you guys
it's over long time ago and everybody's
sitting there talking about pay
attention look yo
over but i tell y'all like it really it
really surprised me that i saw no uproar
whatsoever nothing
nothing
like they they already understand that
there is nothing that they gonna say
that's gonna change anything that's
gonna happen so all they do is just sit
down
i mean we got christopher heart in the
chat talking about yay i'm like yo dude
he tastes involved everything
is they don't realize that all it takes
is that one free-to-play service or that
one gage's service in general that just
hits differently yeah and then before
you know anything
the next fortnight and we know that they
we will say this again we're not just
going to put out all negative
information but with last the world last
of us we all disagreed and felt
ben's studio should get days going too
right that's that's right
we already seen the shift there okay
last of us is the moneymaker we're going
to make another remake that was the
rumor shocked
it jim ryan does chase the engagement
bag no no and that we another thing we
haven't talked about is get it just be
sure about the
mark my words
all of your traditional games
are going to have some form of modeling
what do you think they're going to do
the co-op component you know
what they're going to learn from bungie
what they're going to learn from bungie
is how to put those things in those
games in a way that doesn't look
nasty like loot boxes and egregious
but guaranteed your
your single player games are going to
find more and more ways to extract money
from you that's what happens
what happens the playstation takes us a
different approach where they're like
we're going to have these free-to-play
things to offset our like because
obviously right now we know that that
jim ryan all he cares about is money he
cares about making his numbers look
better this morning
what happens if they go on this mindset
it's like
let's say two or three of these do
really well we make so much more money
and they take some of that money and
invest it more in a naughty dog make
naughty dog have multiple studios
they don't necessarily go straight after
the money but it's just like at the end
of the day i think if anything they
should use bungie with all these like
kind of like you know how
uh respawn right
like having his hand and now all kinds
of cookie jars right now like they're
bungie i feel like they should do that
with bungie where bungie it's like they
don't even go to the top tier unless
bungie says okay that game might do good
go talk to sony now like no for sure
that's what i will say is i do that
louie a little petty king will
appreciate this
it's for all these people
i i get to be petty for once i really
get petty but all these yeah i know i
know you got my timeline
and clipping me and you know that's the
difference and over here it's all about
the organic growth and the nurturing and
tell me where this is organic tell me
where where they started you know they
were they were messing with them back
when they was in high school they knew
them and they brought them a cookie
it was never that it was radically
let me quote let me quote the great jim
ryan we are developer and gamer focused
and entertainment in dna
from our early
acquisitions
and acquisitions just means you did not
start with them of iconic studios
including nori dawg and king where did
naughty dog games play what 3do game did
we play from naughty dog from back in
the day now
they did not originate
wait a second was that a sony game did
sony put that out no
again naughty dog 2001 gorilla holding
these balls gorilla 2005 and sucker
punch productions 20 uh 2011. he said in
addition to our home runs i'm not gonna
say they don't do homegrown but let's
stop this narrative that everything is
nurtured and it's just so organic with
everything that's done they buy things
dude corporations are going to cooperate
period you know if they find a need and
i don't even feel there's nothing wrong
with it all i'm saying is let's just
stop the hypocrisy when one side is
doing it and all of a sudden there's
evil but now we see this other side do
it and it it the energy ain't the same
the only the only thing that could be
that's somewhat true about that
statement is that it their their
willingness to nurture
brand new ibm yes maybe back in the day
microsoft was not going to yes yeah
absolutely that's why we have uncharted
that's what we have last year and i will
give them that yes if you want to go tit
for tat who's nurtured more of course
of course but let's stop acting like
corporations ain't gonna cooperate and
they doing the same acquisitions that
others are doing so just keep the same
energy and let's just stop with the
biases cause that's the part that get on
my nerve when one side do it oh it's a
problem and we gotta go call president
said we gotta go figure it out what's
going on let's keep that energy bro like
that part i don't like hypocrisy
i'm gonna go look because it's hard to
kind of separate them out but i want to
see
the actual the amount of studios that
sony has actually created from the
ground up and if they're still open
today
um but it's that's gonna take forever
that's a sticker we'll just move on but
anyway we got
when it comes to the the whole you know
nurture thing
i i've said it from the start like
it's so much capping with the nurturing
stuff like and you know like i brought
it up last week what k mega said that
really resonated with me like i'm
completely away from the nurturing thing
sure playstation nurtures after they've
bought but i don't really consider that
nurturing until they've actually bought
the company like that whole time they
didn't buy naughty dog that was naughty
dog nurturing naughty dog and when my
when they actually bought them then they
helped with that because like take it
for consider insomnia we really gonna
say for 15 years
uh
they were nurturing insomniac when they
didn't buy them so it's like it's like
if anything what i said last week
naughty dog took the uh and sonia took
this big bag that they were giving them
to make games they were the ones going
out there hiring people they're the ones
that was going through the the process
of nurturing and sony was just funding
they weren't really directly empowered
but here's my thing that's my last point
with it is that
i don't even really care how they do it
because king could appreciate this it's
like you could know your man from the
block back in the day but if his albums
come out in this track it don't matter i
just want the result to be hot i don't
care how you did if you bought in
someone you acquired someone that to me
it shows why i like it is because it
shows yo they recognize a weakness and a
deficiency let's shore up this
multiplayer i respect that yeah i
respect that like microsoft yo you know
why like menudo yeah
you know what we don't do the voice why
is he better we gotta get the mobile up
we gotta get that microsoft
yo we gotta get our rpgs up single
player yo let's get the show up there
there's nothing wrong with as long as
the result and the games are great so
this whole thing is threatens
everybody's uh comfort yeah
they they hear me
they're fearful this is the last
playstation that scares the hell out of
them
that it terrifies you but listen i'm
gonna give you a little piece of solace
i'm gonna give you something to take
with you today as you go on your journey
wherever you may be
it's gonna be a point where you go to
your television and remember i tell you
this isn't going to be an eight or nine
year generation
look where the technology is now in
cloud gaming uh sav and i used to play
on live absolutely terrible now go
upstairs and play xcloud right now
walking down the street while you're
going to the store
and it's amazing right something
incredible now take this same five-year
jump forward
to see where we're going to be
you're going to ask me
as consoles going to be feasible at this
point in time only for the enthusiasts
that you know will have boxes that's
probably eight nine hundred dollars to
uh achieve certain things but then
you're gonna have server blades where
those same things can be achieved at a
resolution of like 1440p 10 1080p 60
frames per second with zer almost zero
latency
this is the hardware that you would be
purchasing
you go right to the store you purchase
this you turn on your tv you hit your
app and you jump right into your game
with zero latency
you guys out here screaming
oh there will always be a
you are willing
to pay money for nothing
you are capping
for no reason you are the same person
telling me
if i play a game
in my game pass
that i paid zero dollars for and you
wouldn't paid 70 for this game
excuse me
all it did is take up space on your
shelf
when you're done with that game it's
taking up space on yourself but i can
sell it back king what to gamestop for
two dollars right so you're not getting
your value back so don't tell me that
you have ownership over said game to
make your money back because you don't
so that's not the proposition you just
been grown on an old metrics that has
outgrown you you need to outgrow that
old metrics and get with the new metrics
where you pay as much as you pay fifteen
dollars
twenty dollars whatever it is on
whatever service lumina whatever stadia
whatever
play as much games as you want
and move on
stop being stop tying yourself down to
these boxes and
nobody ever asks me
about microsoft i believe microsoft get
out that game too
research and development takes up a lot
of cost distribution
and all this stuff takes a lot of you
don't think they just want to make
controllers and just go first
this bet will never because we don't
know how long this generation gonna go
right so
whatever like this could be whatever
king could be right in order generation
could end in six years and we could be
right like i understand what he's saying
i'm just saying that the infrastructure
has to be there in place and i i do
agree with him
that that's what they want
well for you ideally if you get rid of
the hallway i understand that but the
infrastructure i get there get your ball
off and we got to move on we got the
poof
i don't really got much else to say
about it
at the end of the day
um it just depends on exactly the things
that they really go out to to do with
pla with with bungie
i feel like as a destiny player it's
going to benefit me because even if if
it's the worst case scenario and they
make that destiny 3 on playstation i
have a playstation right up there
i care more about destiny as a game that
i care about what platform it's on and
if if there was a realm where destiny
goes away because it's not getting
properly funded to be able to manage two
games
and they do make destiny an exclusive
i'd rather that future than not make
then this doesn't happen they don't make
destiny right so they don't exist
exactly and at the end of the day we got
all the consoles and we we good anyway
so ain't i'm fine whatever happened if
you go left or go right whatever i'm
good i got everything yeah solve we've
got you guys and then super chat
yeah no i know i'm good i'm coming all
right we're good let's get the super
chat because they're right there
i gotta get to this kelly dude these are
hilarious so hold on let me scroll back
one more time we got 918 people in here
man hit that like let's get that over
500 likes
and king will do a backflip in there
that's that's a lie i could do a
backflip when i
if you share it out right now it saves
kittens for only two for only two likes
a day
[Music]
old man can see
sally woke up into some stuff too
please hit the like button it helps the
algorithm
you have to have us come from like off
the camera and sit down and be like
do you like to do do you
think
one like a day you could
this video has nothing to do
this video has absolutely zero to do
about it save the puppies y'all hit the
like button like that hilarious just
like and then it's like for one like a
day you could save a christopher heart
in the chat
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's good fam catching y'all live
while at work i love y'all but i got to
chill on having a show longer than my
work [ __ ]
he's been tugged in as well
pragmatic eagle five thousand chat
current bungie sucks at storytelling
current playstation sucks at multiplayer
shooters hashtag slash live service i
see this as a mutually beneficial
partnership for both parties yes sir yes
sir
and we got lord metro two dollar super
chat sony beta bucks dating the streets
bungees chick yo kings bars on the over
relationship yo it was
classic was classic then we have heart
gates today sodi has movie studios and
playstation amazon has video content and
luna apple making content for apple tv
and likely getting into gaming profit
saab are you with me microsoft needs to
get warner discovery next
i mean
look if if they're if they're going to
get got
i prefer it would be microsoft or
playstation
if they're going to get god i prefer to
be one of those but
we'll see mandingo mcthicker
five dollar super chat so wait
sony overpaid just to be seen with the
sexy uh
uh
escort
[Laughter]
they don't have control or say with
bungie sounds like an arranged marriage
crazy then we have everybody's idol goro
five-pound super chat
phil nah i already beat
yo
yo
yo
that was deep
that was deep
yo
who said that
everybody's idol goro yo that was crazy
girl i know what you're doing bro i know
what you do oh my god let me know what
you're doing and i'm not gonna approve
it
ladies and gentlemen we're trying to
move up the ladder here in the gaming
space you're not helping us well let's
back down
[Laughter]
very messy very messy very messy
[Music]
oh yeah that was the verbiages
actually we have something referencing
that later um
we got somebody's been five dollars
looks like bungie just cucked sony and
you too chris wow
here's some money please tell people
we're together
wow
very messy very messy today there we go
lord roughness high five super chat
somebody going multiplat is the biggest
sign jim dance moves ryan has bent the
knee to phil dominus maximus aurelia
spencer playstation to copy xbox five
years late yeah that's the question i
have for you guys do you think it's
almost like they're really late to the
game though like oh this this service
game thing is is popping like they're
super late to the game really like i
mean you know with anything that might
help them because they can take some of
the bad stuff people done and avoid it
all better
which is why they got bungie yeah so
they don't make those mistakes
we got jd gabriel ten dollars with the
chat sony paid 3.6 billion for a situat
a situation ship
with the only thing that they gained was
the ability to call the girl from the
streets their girl and for her to teach
them how she do that thing she do yo
messy bro wow
this is crazy messy messy this is crazy
we got these are kings fans
that's my family
there we go
that's his heart
then we got digging day remember for
seven months
drinking out of my iron lords beer glass
enjoying the show thanks for the content
bungie slash sony for the streets both
for the streets
put them big glasses up on twitter we're
gonna see them the big glasses yeah yeah
there's a fire in the mugs then we have
his here's what i was talking about todd
davis five dollar super chat sony is
will and bungie is jada sony cool with
bungie having an entanglement
the tag of it is the word
wow
and we got kool-aid 117 5 super chat
word by jimmy boy assist us and
realizing our ambitions to take
playstation beyond the console emphasis
on console without the s
that's it last one okay then we got
gerald mack five dollar super chat xbox
has a mega ton of games as a service
game so bungie wasn't a necessity all
hail the iop salute thank you that is
true
much love then we have north carolina
ghost of lord 10 super chat i believe
we'll get another console generation
after this however i believe that
playstation 6 will be the next dreamcast
though wow
streaming games is far from finished
xbox has console slash pc cloud
playstation will be a app
wow
the same people that thought beepers
will be forever
you say we old
i can never
think that i'll never have a sky pages
shout out to my cell phone mm-hmm
good to you arrow mack two dollar super
chat don't get it twisted bungie's pull
out game is strong
boy
moving on time
i mean it actually don't even really
have to be strong because they're going
to leave with everything anyways
their exit strategy is crazy
um kate johnson five dollars jim ryan is
out here looking like michael jackson
with the way he tap dancing
i like that
there we go jd gamer 10 super chat so
bungie gets a movie career book deal a
tv show and sony gets to put a ring on
it a showpiece on the arm and to drink
their bath water wow now what real man
doing that never marry the hood h whoa
wow he has a bars for sony's not feeling
this move that was extra
for no reason
there we go general mack two dollars
super chat ten games in four years gym
high as f yes he is
then we gotta do it though
[Laughter]
that's crazy though i mean sleeping on
the power gym right i'll bend the knee
if that happens because some people come
for me here too like i i ask the
question and they want to attack me
i'm mad that nobody super chatted the
downgrade on the gran turismo
[Laughter]
so we can talk about that though
we got stitched five dollars jd gamer
are you implying that sony is a sugar
daddy ping for a girl that is friendly
to everybody else and she planning for
the next exit strategy
then we have jd gamer at
5.2 percent now he adds stitch
bungie about to monkey branch to her
next rich daddy as soon as sony says one
unkind word or she get that clout from
the movies and tv shows that's a fact i
want that dlc out next week
[Laughter]
there we go
then we got hard to find two dollars
super chat bungee must have that [ __ ]
that's what i was laughing at whoo and
we got jd gaber adding hard to find
bungie got that whop
dsls and a freaky af time
they want it all
yes then we got sage five dollars in the
chat all playstation first party studios
it's just been announced on playstation
blog all are transitioning to work on
killzone warzone battle royale
that's what's up
then we got free r kelly 5 super chat
much respect y'all king i spoke too soon
it's over
it's over sawing back somebody back on
top people play destiny more than god
oh
yeah
but they're all over the place
call of duty you can only get it in one
spot stop and sit there oh kelly did you
take your match
[Laughter]
back five dollars
the restructuring of the playstation
model was underway they're just looking
for a way to convince the fan base to
accept it
all hail the iop salute gerald mack yes
they already accepted it all right it
feels like it because they're saying a
word no pushback you see christopher
hart in there yay
yay we got we got games of service yeah
y'all they woulda dot yo dude that it's
just weird to me um then we got kate
johnson two dollars super chat get the
bang gays off the knees bending it
it baffles me after years yeah i still
don't understand knees
when did i put up needs for this i asked
i asked the question
whether
objectively do the destiny fans really
feel that destiny could uphold
star wars right
that's a legitimate question i i could
have ripped into them but i don't know
exactly
then we have the rubber knob 20 super
chat
we all know destiny 3 won't be on xbox
when they say multi-platform they're
talking about cloud and pc but we need
to connect that same energy i don't
think so
i i don't i don't know why they don't
read that part where it says rival
console
that's ridiculous yeah i mean they'll
put it on nintendo
until people see it that's going to be
the question when it happened i'm just
sitting there laughing
but we need to keep that same energy we
can't cheer because the game's exclusive
and cry about another
multiplayer multiplayer games is going
everywhere joe mac 2. super chat
uh does donnie boy work at playstation
tv tv tv all hail the iop
back baby yeah
then we got joaquin breath of magic and
domination behind all of this
he was working that budget he back in
joaquin branch five dollar super chat
fam there's some delusions happening
right now if anyone thinks sony can make
a star wars with destiny look up sony's
box office for all their films all bombs
so many films
let's say there's hills and valleys
there you know you can't really drop a
joint right now um uncharted let's go i
mean it doesn't really matter what you
did because like they they they still
making money so they're gonna do it and
people need to get this mentality that
you got to be the best to still do
something effectively no you don't yeah
i think uncharted i think a charter's
going to do well
um we got free r kelly five dollars will
be chat somebody gonna get konami square
and capcom is over oh i mean coming for
kickback i mean r kelly like if you
think sony really is going to get into
like the the gym business and all these
other businesses that these these
companies own konami and square own so
many other businesses you would have to
remove all of gaming from that and just
keep that
right you fronting on jim ryan so he did
say they dot capcom makes sense
he's not done yet d desperate shopping
position right now dudes is pumping up
their numbers jim is outside
we was at six we had 15 right now
they're like jim's outside
play microsoft told us no last week
let's see what playstations yeah for
sale
people people don't realize people don't
realize how complicated it would be to
get konami and square yeah i think it's
just the game it was a miracle that
microsoft was able to get activision
yeah and now
companies are public it gets a lot more
complicated yeah but at the very least
that you know they're about gaming
that's it right
capcom makes sense though yeah free r
kelly once again five thousand which
xbox can keep call of duty cobb and
washed up since black ops 2 it's over
now cod is watching
that
call of duty's washed up and destiny
is the beggar
universe
this is what we live in it's funny what
happens
from week to week that's what i'm saying
that's what it just feels like this i
mean
we can't act like destiny was loved
before this well i mean last week he
gave me his knees from jail
yeah i mean listen i don't know man it
just it just feels like they're so
excited to get like a a response
sometimes the response yeah yeah
they're not they find the big picture
you know what it feels like so i've ever
like do your you know vets and yankees
hot
yeah events we're like yeah we got jason
can do stuff
bay
we're lit we're gonna go yeah we lit i
just mm-hmm
it's not the same but it worked though
didn't it have his desired effect not
first
then we have elementor p.o ten dollars
from chat where we know i jumped it uh
we got jd gamer two dollar super chat so
what happens to bungie when apple buys
sony
they'd be like now this deal can't go
then they leave
element of po 10 super chat if sony
purchased bungie for the infrastructure
know-how as well as then it could have
been a
solid partnership as well as it doesn't
say anything else okay
like sony and microsoft azure there's
got to be more to this that we do not
know about possible yeah very powerful
yeah it's definitely possible
uh jd gamer 500 super chat bungie is a
trojan horse sent by microsoft to
playstation to destroy their just one
hashtag just one single player games
quantity and quality and they are using
jim ryan's greed to do it
yeah
they're gonna pull the plug on the
servers as soon as they get the old
kickballs with the children there we go
todd davis five dollars if you chat
microsoft owned the minority stake of
bungie after they split so it looks like
microsoft made money off the sony buyout
too
i'll get you some money daddy
r kelly five dollars super chat oh that
sounds all nice king but that don't mean
they're dominating for the next 10 years
i don't care how you like it
you're just gonna be upset like right
now you see
i'm glad that you back out the closet
i'm glad that you're here if you're a
present it's before you was in the
corner with your eye
now you out here so i can identify you
and i know exactly how to slay you sir
just sit down and just let us keep going
coming back and forth after one week
he had to buy one game so it took away
two months of him what it was his last
competition he had nothing he could say
but he's like oh i gotta go to iop yeah
you ready
i got something you got something for
kick down
he ain't gonna be super chatting after a
horizon come out so we gotta wait a
couple of months
continue all right and we got the taco
five dollar super chat i did the
research for you saw sony has built 12
studios including support and closed
three but they bought 16 studios and
close five of those
wow
nurture
move them fold them up all right
then we got mexican zoidberg member for
14 months
sony scooped up microsoft's ex-girl mr
steal your girl
trey songz voice wow
we'll raise them babies
then we got jd gamer two dollar super
chat folk stop uh
folks stop shaming bungie they need love
too
my god then we got the wise old gamer i
was waiting for this one five dollars of
attack so what so what you're saying is
that sony signed an open relationship
with bungie now playstation will know
what i've been going through for 18
years
don't be putting your business out there
oh my goodness woo heart get your knee
10 super page 5g rollout will make it
possible to get high performance low
latency internet 5 to 10 millisecond
potential which could make cloud gaming
a reality for casual gamers may still
need console for hardcore gamers
yeah that's what i think i think the
console the hardcore gamers will have a
premium console
rdma3 and all that other great stuff
four or five whatever the hell where we
at and i think those consoles will sell
for seven eight hundred dollars and
price to price you out
and actually target
the controller dudes like just go pick
up a controller and play
that make sense he's preaching the
rubber knob
five dollar super chat addict's hair is
a bird all arguments are invalid addict
let the bird freak
out with my man
like what's going on
why is that bothering you
what is that i don't get that right dude
bungie tim ryan i don't know bungie ti
ryan with not magnum playing easy e no
vaseline i don't
chat we underestimate microsoft they
won't hesitate to keep big service
titles off playstation thank you game
pass 15 million growth since uh 2020 ps
plus three mil growth since 2020. okay
so the sage
then we got gaming for today five
dollars super chat y'all better stop
disrespecting bungie like this treat her
like the high-class escort that she is
wow
you lose
wow for the night then we got lion smack
check 10 super chat i'm not mad at the
acquisitions from sony i think it's cool
that both have studios that play to
their strengths and will improve both
the platforms i got both so it's all
good either way hashtag team x the
salute line smack
then we got lord of roughness five pound
super chat i'm implying sony have been
creating quality bangers because they've
been single player experiences
multiplayer games will be a whole other
story that is true
and then we got suicide kings member for
16 months thank you sir absolute
sony this is my lady i keep her warm
she's with me now bungie say what
microsoft no worries i hit it first
great ray j
wow
wow
my god that was so crazy that's kind of
we caught up they they just pulled they
they pulled us into the toilet today
baby then we got element appeal five
dollar super chat sony borrowing money
because they are in the red to buy a
studio and tell us microsoft where you
at
are you stupid
and i was [ __ ] that broke dude
[Laughter]
definitely gonna dave and shave you
today of a dominance for the uh premium
team anonymous brought a snapback and
then saw read that last one and we got
to move forward there you go look at all
of this all i'm saying is you shouldn't
have been able to buy that team yeah you
know that's what i say we got a
[Music]
this is something we're willing to delay
the show
[Laughter]
get away from that store they've been
going they've been going off the street
for two weeks you're gonna shut the
store down
you're gonna fold teespring for the day
you just hear king says recount recount
them
all right cake show king sent me the
evidence that he got receipts all right
he got the evidence that he went to one
of our own shop gurus that he did put in
the request all right so he got he got
his defense
that was just drawing
last week but a good
did you wait till like tuesday wednesday
oh it's still live no
it's okay listen good marketing leaders
make sure that that was actually
yesterday after the meetings
for you eat this one
are you good with good song i know we
got two words
we got soma king three pounds super chat
don't dis jim liking sloppy
seconds she said wow yeah we got lord
metroid two dollars over that sony likes
the jam used and the jar half used wow
wow
good
more
you guys are undefeated yeah oh no we're
good
cool we gotta get these last two um all
right so this is me
and one more sorry okay while i get
myself
mr two opinionated five dollar super
chat don't make fun of this bungee deal
sony still gets to cuddle on the weekend
yo that was funny all right that was
there we go
as requested king what happened to gt7
oh no
anyway thank you so nobody's talking
he's like funny that you funny that you
should mention that everybody's talking
about nobody's talking about the
downgrades like nobody's talking about
ray tracing only in the picture mode
nobody's talking about seeing this yeah
cause i remember the first time i see
one
and the call looks incredible stop
buying it
[Laughter]
yo y'all didn't buy it right but now
that they're supposed to be down y'all
just running willy-nilly in the store
just expose exposing the great
management of our marketing leaders
y'all are disrespecting me right now
this is bad business
anyway
no you know you know they take the
opportunity to jump in you notice we got
the wise old game with five dollars
let's hope sony doesn't leave this
relationship with bungie with something
they can't get rid of wow
[Laughter]
the only time i'll talk personal but
i've been gone because i had finals i'm
20 in undergrad but i'm back
oh i'm glad i'm glad respect that
brother i'm glad you can get your
diploma absolutely
don't be stupid you should don't do him
like that don't do him like that
don't do him like that listen he's 20
and underground
getting his education are you a little
too old to be are you talking about all
kelly
yeah you're too young for that that
username but we respect your vision yeah
kelly don't like that name
associate yourself a little something
else for you for your new journal
all right all week all right we're good
let's go let's all right finally get in
touch real quick all right mlb the show
mlb
let's go oh you turn the camera off hold
on mlb the show announced during the
reveal event the sony first party game
will now be available on playstation 5
ps4 xbox series x s xbox one
and now
covered in hot then
don't switch whoa switch gang stand up
who said baseball baseball
who wants to play baseball i love
baseball baseball has been very very
good to me
[Music]
has allowed baseball to be
baseball has been very very good to me
with all my baseball i cannot wait to
play baseball and led the show in game
pass day one
oh
playstation dude 70 dollar
[Music]
we will play baseball together unified
okay
moving on as i was saying you'll be able
to play and carry save data across all
platforms by creating mlb the show
account the game will once again hit
xbox game pass on launch day it's also
like i said for the nintendo switch will
feature cross save cross play and cross
progression across all congregations
yes so let's get to it let me start with
solve on this basketball space gotta
break protocol oh yeah stuff you're
always so addicted you know we will no
no no no no that's good let's go
this is this is for us
shout out to
mlb the show 22 once again gracing game
pass on day one
because you know what that means for me
right it means that the only platform
that's getting my baseball money this
year is the nintendo switch oh
you train are you going switch coming up
with me why are you covering switch over
the hand tell me about this play cross
say cross progression
that we got to talk about game game pass
is death we want to keep us off when i'm
so we really do we know what the
performance targets are going to be
listen
listen i i'm captain if i see it and
it's so disgusting that i can't
i won't but if it's serviceable
you'll continue your season on it
come on
because there's no pc version if there
was a pc version and i could reasonably
expect to be getting my steam deck this
year
i'd wait okay
okay but that's not happening but king i
got to bring king into the fold
what happened to your heart alexis
i was hoping that would pc would play
the baseball
why we can't play the players
game pass
i i i i i i
i am only here for game fast
these nixes you talk of i know nothing
of mixes
[Laughter]
[Music]
shout out yo you dudes oh my god
i
i waited for this moment since last year
does it happen y'all was like oh it's
only gonna be one time king next time
you understand you're gonna have to
double up and pay for that
phil
dominus maximus cerealis spencer
lifetime achievement owner
you think you think last year's deal was
just multi deal from the right that's
why
like because at this point
i'm gonna be honest this is okay like i
i didn't know we knew it would be
multi-plat but i guess my concern was
you know was the game past things i feel
like phil want to make a splash he'd do
that one time you hit him with the bag
but clearly they like the relationship
with mlb i'm giving right back to you
okay so my question is like do you think
it's just a a moat like phil just made a
multi-year deal and this is how it's
gonna be for a couple of seasons okay
jim
saw the money
that was this shift
games of a service all of a sudden
we got to do this thing we got to get
this money outside the box he realized
you ain't enough like he
he said oh man he started getting pc
money he started seeing money from game
pass he started seeing stuff he just
realized that you guys are always going
to be suckers and gonna be there
my biggest problem is out of this whole
thing okay yeah i'm gonna be the show i
can joke i can laugh i can key key all i
want
i'm gonna be playing it you playstation
dudes that was really down with them
that was supporting them why is it not
in playstation now why is it not in
playstation plus i don't care if they
give it to you for a month the game is a
first party game that's made by them why
are you paying for the game and i'm not
all right let me ask you this though in
fitness i hear where you going i know it
like as far as them being in this
service but like
this deal let's just be honest in this
particular one it doesn't feel like sony
had to say initially on how this going
do they have a say on putting it aside
they services well what if but we know
for i mean we kind of assume that when
microsoft would structure a contract
like this it can't be at a competing
subs you know rival service so what if
it's just the mlb and microsoft is to
the side and how old
yeah
and how ill is filled if it comes to
that right there oh he this is what made
him to go for me as far as look y'all
know what peterborough but you remember
king you remember the fate of the day
2015 aaron greenberg phil spencer
cognito first beating him in the flesh
and i'm like yo
he's like what you what i'm like where's
the baseball game
y'all don't got no he did that for me he
did that for me so this is what i okay
what did he tell you the best simulation
baseball gold thank you sir he did tell
you that don't worry we're working on it
yes he did what type of work is this
this is witchcraft and he made i
remember that day last year he made it
his business to tweet we are so happy
and excited with the mlv the show like
they it was a marketing blitz like they
wanted it again this year yeah i was
surprised but here's the nintendo thing
i love that let's talk about it
man that bag baby
dude switch is about to overtake
switch it's
it may not ever overtake playstation 2.
but the switch is just it's selling
gangbusters like that's crazy
on the strength of just being out there
it's going to sell so just so yeah
yep that's it yeah that's the only
baseball game on it and to me it's like
mlb is just looking at it like yo look
at this brad we love what the numbers
did last time now let's put it on that's
what i'm now the question is why is it
pc simultaneously is it still so thick
so they may be holding on to it i think
the day
yeah i think they're still ramping up
san diego san diego i guess had to grow
some to be able to put out this extra
version of the game
it's a lot of work i mean these these
guys literally take nine months to make
every new game honestly i got bungee now
so
if you're attic you're talking you're
muted because i see you moving with that
part of me feels like
because when it comes to sports games
you don't really see those at pc like
that so
i don't think madden's on pc question pc
game pass y'all i can't remember last
year was it on pc game pass
no there's no pc version last year
yeah i think there's no pc version
yeah there was no pc version of the game
it still isn't correct correct so that's
the thing so i'm thinking next year they
ramp up to have all of those versions
out
the thing is is what exactly
is because
nick said mata is on piece i think
that's just recently too i don't think
it's like something that just you know
been there for a while i think they just
recently started putting madden on pc
it
i've just noticed like with the 2k
community like
they can't stand that game on pc like
that that game's constantly like
it's you know it's the pc people man
they they
are
not it's a lot of cheating and you know
that that's what it is like when it
comes to those type of games like
there's a lot of cheating going on
especially those like one-on-one type of
games i'm not saying
that there's going to be
a huge like there's no chance that the
game comes to pc but it's just like we
might come later i just don't think it's
going to be one of those things like
it's day and date yeah that's what we
might see the game come out six months
from now but i've noticed like a lot of
a lot of
platform holders and a lot of publishers
in general they're on that
okay we want this on pc
but do we really want to delay the game
to make sure it's on pc game one so
we're still going to release this on
consoles and we'll get to the pc version
down the line that's what it seems like
to me the most yeah i mean it is
interesting um
again i was i was surprised to see this
and it just shows that the relationship
is
is definitely bubbling and they like
what they see so money talks
yeah and let's be real and soft could
appreciate this
major league baseball as a sport
is really waning in the popularity from
how it used to be nfl or whatever it
being all stuff they've got to do
something to get more eyes on this so i
could totally understand mlb's position
like yo we got to open this up we need
this game is a great game like it really
is like the switch yeah and the thing
about the switch is even though it is a
simulation baseball game
the switch there's so many switch
households have multiple switches yes a
lot of them will switch lights that
means that they're in the hands of
children to be honest you have to to
grow the base that loves baseball you
have to get the kids early right yeah
yeah if you don't get to kids early with
baseball adults for the most part are
going to look at baseball be like this
is boring well also the price of
baseball is no longer what it used to be
like you know you're going to uh a game
uh baseball has priced itself out with
the with the the bowl seats down at the
bottom
compared to the outfield seats um prices
for a game can range from upwards to a
hundred dollars for you and your son
you and your daughter you know very easy
and then you go into concessions and
stuff like that it's kind of crazy like
bleacher seats bleacher seats and
concessions for two people are gonna run
you close to 150 dollars anywhere yeah
see that's that's so good that's that's
no longer um what the uh american
uh
experience is when it comes to sports i
i believe in sports in general um we
have priced out the the patrons
and we've made it uh an event you know i
can see how football
only 16 to 18 games
i can see how that can be an event type
of thing exactly baseball has a 182
games i think it is 62.
so long yeah
yeah so
those things
they have to price it
that you can get the kids in that you
know that you know you can get the the
young kids in to get enthusiastic about
the sport because remember the sport is
long it's drawn out some games can be
boring some games aren't as exciting but
you have to make it so that it's an
experience that they enjoy going to get
a hot dog with their pops on their minds
you know sitting there with their uncles
or their aunts or whatever family type
of things yeah and you can y'all have a
great experience i think that part has
pushed baseball to the side because it's
not as exciting as it's supposed to be
and financially they're pricing itself
out now this is a good way to reach
children to get them at least
inquisitive enough about the sport yeah
to go there and like you said on switch
i think that
really
ignites the imagination for the child
but it just does
get it
i don't know coming from a person that
didn't that wasn't raised in a sports
house
right if they're not in a sports house
there is a chance they still go towards
that they have friends that get in
sports they get introduced into a
younger age from friends
but if you don't really have an outlet
of someone to introduce you to that type
of scenery you're not going in i was not
going to gravitate to i agree but i will
say and i feel like i feel like a lot of
people that aren't into sports
not going to buy this anyway but here's
the thing i will say this i know where
you're going but you know for me
like come on we grew up in you know
south bronx it wasn't no hockey rinks
running around i remember when nhl 94 or
whatever it was came out number two
games i'm like yo this is really good
good-looking games and you try it and
then you start to get into this book all
i'm saying is you're probably right
overall at it but what probably the
mlb's big thought process is like if a
few people get to try this amazing game
they may end up falling in love with a
sport that they may have never crossed
paths with because yes
like they're they're blind marketing
we all know you out there but you may
want you yeah a demographic that's like
okay cool and whatever whatever but yeah
that's pretty much not to not to mention
the people that will double dip oh yeah
right yes that that market yeah yeah
that market whatever the crosstalk
that's why we're smarter with the cross
saving across platforms yeah you got it
free and game pass so you can save your
eyes and game pass and then
go bust out cataracts
the link to the 10k shirt does not work
he got them
wait hold on check right now let me see
if we can put it up we can see if we can
put it up right now get our great
marketing leader out of here you have
been stopped
i
can y'all access it
you have been stopped
the lick too long they won't let me put
the journey in my baby yeah right
i'm going to decide i don't see it at
the top of a paul probably looks in the
pocket
i don't see you it might be gone y'all
it might be good it was on the timeline
it was at the top of your at the top
disrespect me and get in there and go
shopping when i said that it's no longer
[Laughter]
because mr irishman i was trying to get
you to link to buy it and we could troll
king some more but yeah
when it comes to artwork sometime this
year we are going to try something new
oh yeah we're going to do some things at
it came up with some great ideas and
we're definitely going to use those
ideas because i love that stuff i love
everything that he talked about and i
think you guys will love it too so i'm
me and him i'm going to sit down we're
going to kind of talk
first and then we're going to go on and
we're going to do it at a cadence and
when i say stop it will be stopped
yo somebody point one
nah you had it you had it in the box
yeah he had it he had it in the shopping
cart probably what was that
they beat it they beat them anonymous
that was you
[Laughter]
the hoodie and the tumbler
he probably he probably had it up before
it was took out he got it up yeah but no
this purchase was at 4pm
so when okay when you eliminate that do
you eliminate the entire line or is it
just the shirts going because we got
people we gotta take the merchandise
we gotta see how it works maybe the list
is probably on the back of the camera to
go yell at
it
if you
if you have the link you can still go to
it yes until thick and official and
probably still yeah the back yeah all
right so cool we shout out to the
lawrence vms
embarrassing our marketing leader i love
it continue it all the time
i'm sorry
and then we move on to the final yeah
i thought you and i was friends dude i
thought i thought i represented you guys
and y'all out here y'all could have
brought anything but that t y'all could
have saw the t it was like nah you know
what the king gonna get the flack i'm
not gonna purchase that t you could have
went and got a beanie there's another
one oh they put it in blues if there's a
way to trail troll king i'll take it
love you guys somebody got the old link
and they're using it because they just
they got some discord that they passed
all right
yeah it's still up bro good good though
yo if y'all got the link post that
let everybody eat let's sit in the chat
post it in the chat if y'all got it
look at ken king's on his face i'm tired
boss kid against not helping him go post
of choice y'all keep him coming nobody
getting fired today we had 12k but we go
still promote them 10k joints he don't
like
wow
i told you
last week to get rid of it and then i
told you the week before
about to get fired
[Laughter]
shout out for not taking the link down
king looking at the claws right now can
i get rid of him without getting in
trouble
so i'm going to super chat for you
man
we talked yesterday man
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we got jean-marc louis two dollars with
a chat soda's on the wrong end of this
entanglement yes
okay hold up there's people that
generally want one look send me the link
on twitter we'll put it in the chat but
this is literally your last time a
chance to get one like this isn't no
joke until next week with king forget
again
whoever bought that send me the lane
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god wow
there we have nc ghost of lord 5 super
chat i'm downloading the show again just
to embrace playstation's future another
one
sega fans dream come true thank you
even nintendo gets to hit this one wow
this is
so much innuendo here
this is somebody yo i'm telling you
guys
yeah it's [ __ ] he told cocktail maddie
he told me he told me acg
would do something like that this is
gotta be acg
let us pixel bit g g10 casey let us eat
so
tell me in the chat who has the one
somebody got it they're running white
gamers
like
jonathan b i know i've sent you stuff in
the past on twitter give me your that
link
give me that link
a little story time real quick yeah my
brother was hit me up and he was asking
about nfts right
and uh because he he didn't know any
about them he's like yo he's like
you guys should do nft so like exactly i
was like the gaming industry it's not
about them in my teeth we'd get
[Applause]
[Music]
for seven months i'm jumping right now
you said king watching these 10k sales
like prepare the guillotine
all right jonathan b i have i made you a
moderator post it in the link no no
then we got necromancer's sail five
dollars super chat share the link i need
the link to buy a 10k
wow
message wow this is f hello
yeah no no we get it let me jump back a
little bit
um
then we got hearty chitty again five
dollars would chat now wouldn't it be a
kick in the in the arse if xbox signed a
deal with the mlb that the show can't go
in competing subscription services
spartacus can't have the show that would
be hilarious
um yeah i know they're snitching crazy
lord metroid two dollars over that no
baseball classic no put no pr team so
the show it is you're playing that show
yeah you know baseball is you know
baseball classic
element 5 super chat why would you need
to switch for mlb when you can play on
cloud anywhere looking better than 640p
at 20fps i've once again my particular
situation my job has me most of the time
i'm in a sub basement somewhere yeah i
am it's not okay i'm happy yeah i can't
ex-cloud that need that i need i need
local i need a little so you know i'm
gonna make do with what it is until i
get my steam back you know well granted
growth kia walking y'all foul
yeah business where it's
and we got nathan langston five dollar
super chat love the lord's day also not
approved but thanks for not swearing oh
i can listen to the show with my son
very inclusive and non-toxic love thank
you sir that's it that's what we're all
about that's very important that's
important for us very important to me
absolutely all right we are caught up i
believe
let me make sure you got necromancer did
you get
um no you guys
i read those couple after the next after
necromancer that pixel bit g shout out
to excellent g now yeah 2000 super chat
shout out to the chat too funny let us
eat
what say
forte five dollars that's copyright
material bearded panda i need my voice
he did he didn't run with your boss all
right all right i found it i found it
unbelievable all right
is
the link and it's like i do not like you
and i will never do that to you
gonna and your mouth said she was gonna
stop this we're getting you
he ain't taking his mom off to take it
moving oh no it's off um let's get to
the final topic of the day what what's
all right with sifu
okay so so uh
just generally uh i believe seafood has
been getting some great reviews so we'll
talk about my short experience with it
at the end of this little segment but
the beginning i'm going to talk about
the messiness and i'm sorry lord king
you my dude but this shirt is fire let
the blasphemy 10k continue salute sorry
continue i'm reading all those
superhearts saying let's go sifu sony
greatness no there's no greatness there
today
not the game all right so this is what
happened to everybody who who
pre-ordered the deluxe edition to be
able to play it today instead of the
regular release date which is tuesday
um the countdown was there for people
who pre-ordered um and you were supposed
to be able to play if you're on the east
coast you probably play at seven seven
a.m this morning or three a.m on the
west coast
when you got down to to the end of the
countdown you should have been able to
have downloaded the game already way
before that the game was not downloaded
yet when you get to the the all the
zeros and you get to the end of the
countdown and you expect to be able to
play the game early 48 hours early
um the link was not working so you could
neither download your game
you can neither download your game nor
play it
right um apparently that this has been
rectified since this morning so it
apparently works now that's that's good
it's fixed apparently yeah that's what i
heard is fixed okay um
but what i did because i was not about
that foolishness
i have very set gaming times and when i
set aside time for fun
nothing is going to impede my fun
so i will be getting a refund for that
deluxe version on the playstation that i
did not get to play i jumped right over
to the epic game store and bought it
where i should have bought it to be oh
we got up-to-date tweets bro all right
let me read you from the sifu account
all right the playstation teams have
told us that the early access issue is
now resolved and the game can now be
downloaded again we're very sorry to all
players who were hoping to play earlier
today and we have an exclusive gift for
all deluxe edition holders to share with
you soon then 16 minutes if you're still
having issues with the game could you
please send us your playstation network
id in the dms
with the reason platform you're using so
we can forward the information to the
playstation these 10k shirt
notifications playstation ideas that are
tracking the
if it still doesn't work the playstation
team also advised to test the following
go to settings user accounts others and
restore licensing so yeah they've been
really busy this morning trying to get a
hold of this issue so and this is a
playstation issue so shout out to y'all
for folding everything i thank you this
is why they call it an xbox podcast
so anyway so i moved over to epic game
store and by that time i was only able
to get about two hours in with the game
um when i tell y'all that the two hours
that i played of this game mm-hmm
[Music]
it's us
when we talk about channel 5 and the
origins of the lords and where we come
from let's go
this is
the game that i think best exemplifies
what we felt when we would sit down
saturday afternoons right after right
after wrestling
driving movies let's go
this game um so let me set up a little
bit about the game without saying too
much about it at all um it's pretty much
set up like what you would expect the
plot to be of one of those movies right
it's not then the plot isn't anything
that we haven't seen before um but what
happens
wow i is keep up with this
for king's knees and tears somebody
mister he got the tumblr yo
yo i'm gonna get to all the shout outs
yeah i can't keep up until you finish
yeah yeah yeah i mean i mean the
the bank gonna look nice though much
much love for being objective about it i
just like that with kick messed up we
could explode
i didn't mess up this is the whole
problem
i handled the situation yesterday
i admit i go fast 76 you need the link
there you go listen oh my god listen i i
admit
it during the week and when we realized
at the meeting yesterday i said okay
i'll handle it send out the information
talk to my situation and the situation
was told
in the chat again
unbelievable
this is not good
i got you guys though
let's get back to the seafood finish
because this is way better than anything
you could possibly do all we got to do
is just end the show and it's over
[Laughter]
finish your songs
this game this game is the marriage
between
an eight-bit beat-em-up like that we
like street charades some of that is the
perfect match between that
and a fighting game the depth of a
fighting game okay okay um so basically
the whole conceit of it is that you you
go through these scenarios where you're
fighting a bunch of different enemies
and
it kind of plays a little bit like a
road rogue like where it's they're
technically called runs right and during
the runs you can you you can get like
special moves and stuff like that um and
upgrades that are only sort of
good for that run until you die
and then you start to run over but the
thing about it is every time you die
your age goes up you start at age 20 you
start at age 20. so the trade-off is
that every time you die you come back
older
a little bit stronger and a little less
fast
so the thing is what you want to try to
do this is where the run thing comes
into play because the thing about it is
you want to try to get through each
scenario with as few deaths as possible
by the time you get to the end closer to
the end of the game
you i think you die officially fully die
at 70 years old oh okay so so what you
want to try to do is
go through each scenario as unscathed as
possible yeah so that you're still
fairly young so you can use those lives
later on when the game gets much harder
um
so that that's the cool conceit of the
game right
um when it comes to the move sets and
everything you're able to do um when i
tell you that it it feels like an action
movie like what we see in action movies
where you're utilizing you know the back
and forth in combat you know
person-to-person combat is amazing the
different moves you unlock really really
really expand the combat in a way that
you don't expect in like a size golden
type beat-em-up game
if that's why i said it's really like a
fighting game oh this this is ridiculous
this this is what's happening right now
i can't concentrate yeah it's literally
the 10k shirt keep popping up with
people talking all on your face
slandering kids
it's hilarious like literally it's been
superimposed that's how much they've
been buying
um
so that that's kind of
[Music]
while they disrespect me
i'm going to be listening to solve
unboxings
i need to get some form of peace here
you guys have definitely taken me out yo
isn't these guys the names they're
putting on these
you're still the man king i love you but
but
i can't tell you
let's see if we're talking about y'all i
bet you can't go to remember to take
those 20 questions
you can learn about that
so
i'm going to tell y'all right now yeah i
finally do play this hopefully cog you
play it later i know addict this is not
a game for you um it's not an out of
game anymore but you're so funny
i would like to see you play this type
of game i would love to see him play
this i would love to see him play this
here because it's not a fighting game in
the sense that you're you're you're
learning you're fighting npcs you know
i'm saying you're not
so let me get to the battle toads and
then i'll think
and by the way the last week i was
supposed to do the battletoads monday
but that's literally the exact same day
yeah that was the bungie you weren't
gonna i was like
after that bungie thing i was like this
whole week's pretty much yeah it's a
wrap
so uh just to end off because i've only
played two hours of it yeah the two
hours that i played
are absolutely amazing
for for the type of game that i was
looking for from this you know when you
see something and it immediately calls
your attention like this is for me but
sometimes they let you down yes they
didn't let us to handle it okay
animations how we feeling hit the
animations okay so the the art style is
kind of painterly uh it doesn't have a
lot of textures to it okay it
but it works for the fluidity of the
game i think right i re i would love to
see slow clap games with a budget like a
big budget to be able to do what they
really want to do um
i have no gripe so far everything that
i've seen in terms of what i've been
able to unlock and how to i apply that
to the to the game
um there's so much depth to the fighting
that it can kind of become overwhelming
but for guys who like us who come from
fighting games and dude there's okazami
what's up
there's okazama in this game oh language
you could drop down
and you could stay and wait
and you can and you can kind of see
where the attacks are coming from you
could jump over it under attack like
over tax and duck under attacks in a way
that opens up
your opponent to like counters when i
tell you the depth is there okay and
it's just a matter of kind of grinding
how we used to do getting in the dojo
and getting better and better
um the game from what i've seen so far
is right up our alley okay i think
you're gonna love it this is my
highlight loki this was my more
anticipated thing than horizon piano
like this was the game for me i was like
this is me all day that's why i was
hurting me when the pre-download wasn't
ready
to play it you'll be able to play it now
and i i'm telling you yeah i want i want
the phone call later yeah uh how much is
the game because i'll probably pick it
up on um it's 45 oh that's good that's a
good price for them yeah there you go
yeah
so if you get if you pay if you pay the
45 you can play it right now i don't
care for the deluxe how much is the
regular the regular uh it's like it's
still 39.99 oh so then i give them the
40 bucks
because the 45 is because oh do you have
ps plus i don't think so no you don't no
i do not sir okay so yeah there's no
value there so it'll be it'll be it'll
be 50 bucks especially now because come
on dude
then it'll be when i i'll wait to get
the regular then
but you saw what about last question um
the the i've heard the difficulty is it
dark souls level or is it cause i spoke
to matty a little bit he won't be mad if
i say it's not because the reviews are
out but he was just like
it's it's tough he said it's tough and
he just said but he said he said cop
you're gonna love it and he pretty much
was like there are some times where the
ai can get cheap sometimes yes
um so the i will say this so far like i
said i've only i've only finished like
the first scenario and started the
second scenario um
they it can get a little overwhelming
because they will attack you in bunches
right
um when it comes to powering you know i
love parrying and
so the thing is most of the time when
you're blocking
expect the three-hit combo at the very
least with some
when you try to get a parry off yeah
right
and you miss your block right
so you should hold the block for at
least three hits because they could come
at you with a combo and then try to
counter um so what happens there
parrying is a little difficult because a
lot of times
just to animate it'll be extra frames of
mathematician you don't expect so you
have to hold on to that parry a little
bit longer parrying's going to open your
opponents up to like grabs and stuff
like that tossing them to into different
environmental sort of like
another thing that's very cool is that
the fact that you can use the
environment to your advantage you have
weapons thrown throughout the
environment um there's certain
animations that can depending on what it
is it'll do a specific animation for
like ramming the guys heading to a table
stuff like that like oh
what this is this is funny let's go
there is no
he beats up women the same way
this game like a win
don't filter b he beats everyone with
your character can be a male or female
oh that's nice
yeah um i don't know when it comes to
when you when you get into the flow in
the moment-to-moment combat
um
when i when i face the first boss the
first boss
is
that that
battle
it was really just channel five standing
in the pocket
and bobbing and weaving him and when you
bob and weave him you see your openings
you attack and it's a it really is a
matter of staying focused paying
attention to the tells that their
opponent has for you
and
learning
just how we always fought in tekken like
good fighting technique what counters
this what counters that and the fact
that
you have this sort of uh this skill tree
that expands considerably throughout the
game i'm excited to see what i can do
with all these different moves once i
unlocked and we got the
do we got the flying kicks do we got the
um
how's the stat or like how's his like is
he is he more like like someone chung or
some like how's his style
what's how i feel
it feels like straight up kung fu like
so there isn't a kick button there's two
attack buttons one is strong attack and
one is light attack and they mostly
initiate with punches they'll go into
combos that are kicks that are kicks but
there's only really two attack buttons
so you have
a light attack
well it's pre-canned like the combos are
there like
like like virtua fighter virtual fighter
didn't have a button that corresponded
to every single limb right but depending
on directions and stuff like that and
how long you hold the button all those
sort of sorts of things determine the
the type of attack that comes out like
if you're moving forward you're moving
backwards and then again you unlock more
combos as you play as well
so the variety is definitely there does
the proximity of the um environment uh
dictate uh what combos that you're going
to do like if they're up against a wall
you can do like a different type of
devastating combo
it'll animate accordingly it'll animate
accordingly like you push them up
against the wall you're the next hit
you'll you can tell that he's
like he's up into the wall and whatever
sometimes you can even take the head
bash it into a wall like stuff like that
like it is really it seems so vibrant
yeah i love it
yeah i love it all this let's go what
about the whole thing like he's getting
it seems like he's always outnumbered
right he's always on like how's the
switching of the focus between so that
you ain't getting jumped so i that's
where maddie is talking about a little
bit of cheapness because what happens is
again when you're fighting one person
the other one's just none of that we're
waiting around until you're done with
this oh yeah because you're going to
over the gaze
you have to be you have to be cognizant
of the people coming from behind you
trying to hit you right
and it's not like it's not forgiving
like batman right batman you're counting
all of them all different directions no
you could like again if you're attacking
somebody right and they start to block
and you see their their buddies coming
up from behind you and trying to hit you
from the back what's going to happen is
that if you manage to parry perfectly
right you master parry perfectly
you can sort of stun that guy and combo
him and try to focus on someone else or
whatever try to finish him off
if you don't you just block yeah chances
are you can start getting hit by two or
three people at a time and you're
blocking all that and what happens is
that your stamina starts to go down
right
and then
right and the thing is so at that point
you got to try to get out of there a
little bit so
there's like so yeah so you have you
have a run button that's kind of like
you can rush into moves right there's
certain moves that will use the run
button you can rush in but it's also in
conjunction with the left analog stick
it allows you to dip and dodge out of
situations whatever there's also a
mantle button that allows you to sort of
jump over like tables and stuff like
that so if you're getting beaten up on
one side of the table whatever you need
to escape real quick jump up jump over
onto the other side slide over here it
reminds me of games like dead to rights
okay um
the stranglehold remember strength yes
yes yes
young fat yeah
those are more gun based right but the
idea of this fluid movement that
incorporates the environment and
everything just happens in this very
cinematic way
they've gotten it right in a way i i
never i never thought we'd see the day
now the art style again our style is
cool it's nice and it serves its purpose
because of that smoothness that's why i
said i want to see them with a budget
but
put a lot of the environments like the
environments
you see like the foliage
don't show so don't show addict number
two
number two
yeah yeah yeah that's what i'm looking
for okay yes all i got to see is those
bushes
last question so like
are we getting that classic channel 5
martial art
like narrative where it's like my kung
fu like wait where are we at with the
narrative like is that the boss come
down they talking that talks is it is it
more spiritual zen like where are they
actually so
it's mostly grounded but then there is
supernatural things in it you'll see it
right okay um it's mostly grounded um
when it comes to narrative it's like i
said it's what you'd expect from one of
those movies so let's think about you
know
revenge tales and stuff okay okay okay
okay
so when you get past 70 because you get
powerful but every time you die but more
slower 70s just game over after you die
i believe 70 is where you die like when
they kill you because a lot of times
when they kill you in the game right
it'll show it'll show the amount of
years that it's tacking on to your age
right yeah and then you wake up and like
for instance when i went from 27 to 30
i had the beard like i you stole the
beard and then they're like and then
your opponent is like it starts you
right back where you died so the
opponent is like what the hell
oh
how you came back
like dude is it the english or was it
the dog but where we are oh it's the
english i don't know if this is dub i
don't know maybe there is
but the english the english is very good
like the the production value in terms
of the way the story is told the way the
the characters emote and like the
beginning of the game where it tells you
like you know the beginning sort of
exposition dump whatever um is good one
thing i didn't like and again it goes
back to the budget yeah it's not that i
disliked it is when you get to the end
of the the first area the first stage
not the initial stage when you start the
game but after you start the game proper
right and you get to the first
quote-unquote boss
um
for me there should have been a more
emotional residence there story-wise
and it just kind of
it
it ended and it it sent you right back
to like your headquarters and i was like
for what this dude did it should not
happen i needed more so to me it's like
it's one of those things like the story
is is serviceable in in in service of
the action that you're going to be
partaking in but i wish they had more
money you want more money yeah because
you know sony would have more of them
cinematic more likes between stage stage
but i'm telling you the moment the
moment when you start dipping and
dodging out and then countering yeah
all right cool let's get the um what you
call it while you queue up the super
chats i will get the poll
yo blaze you coming on the the hand me
the knees when
you're ridiculous oh let's see that you
might want to finish the merchandise
though yeah
i'll do them i got the merch lined up i
got the much ready to go but i'll go
down a second let me see then langston
was the last one i believe yeah i got
the poll while you are
with sony's recent acquisition of bungie
which outcome do you think is most
likely to happen as a result of the deal
choices are a bungie will now have
proper financial support for destiny and
new franchises plus leverage sony's tv
and film connections
b sony's multiplayer games will increase
and live service offerings will be
enhanced with bungie's expertise
c
bungee and sony's marriage will clash
long-term in philosophy leading to an
eventual split once again for bungie or
d
i don't care i'm still all about these
natural and organic studio acquisitions
shout out to everybody in the realm it
should be up now again good to be back
with just the laws i missed this i
missed this
i mean we love guests we love guests but
you know we try to make a concerted
effort to
bring at least one of these back
hopefully true but a month and and just
with the assets this is what made us who
we are this right here king is making
statues he's promoting he's got his
stuff
about to put her over there with cable
you know this was mystique one time
then we got flame to love super chat we
in here singing take me out to the t
space
i'm feeling that
then we got jd gamer
is sifu was entertaining as good as afro
samurai um in terms of i know the afro
samurai game is good i don't play the
game
i mean when it comes to is if afro
samurai is more of this about the show
it's about the cartoon right so it's
it's more the action is more sort of
arcady
and it's linear yeah so this is linear
but the the moment-to-moment action the
combat is really it could get really
deep this combat yeah
um okay then we have
we got splendiferous two dollar super
chat
you can call it the art of fighting
without fighting
there is you there is this thing where
you can when you walk into engagements
like you can walk in like slowly like
walk into the situation be like yeah
what's up
let's go let's go like and you can or
you could rush in like that you you'll
have enemies sometimes that are not
looking at you
you rush and be behind them and just
boom and then you immediately can get a
finisher off on that right what's up
mm-hmm
all right usually we ought to snuff
people
there's a snuffs in the lips
stuff's in related yeah it's definitely
in there
um
that's it all right cool and 10k brigade
again last one was picture big g um from
the initial wave classic t king let us
eat smitty smith lil king you might do
but this shirt is fire let the blasphemy
continue salute anonymous classic t-10k
hoodie anonymous another classic 10k
hargit shanique what a glass sorry kid
had to do it hashtag king dethrone he
got it in a baby blue 10k dano brought a
classic tea i'm gonna enjoy every sip i
get out of this bub while wearing my
shirt he got the 10k monk
brown sugar 720 brought a premium long
sleeve 10k let the revolution continue
let the people eat 10k you got that in
white black ronin brought the tribe
blend
like thanks for letting me support the
show and tease lord king the realm is
the best mr irishman got that stainless
tumbler 20 ounces for kings knees and
tears just put them in the thing
romance is hell brought a kicktastic 10k
t keep buying these for king
jd gamer brought up premium 10k gotta
pick up some merch
and td lee classic team don't worry king
this is an all-natural situation
don't doubt you got the 10k in purple d
scales h town classic tape had to be
part of history
wise old gamer classic he got the 10k
classic crew net sweatshirt hey king
this is my monthly viagra money it was
worth it don't have anyone to use the
viagra with anyways
[Laughter]
yeah boy king you still the man i
brought a classic crew neck t-shirt um
these skills h-town again with two black
sweaters and another shirt had to be
part of history and knows where the
final run let's go
close this off get this super chat
so
that was it okay here we go ta checks
eleven thirty eight five dollar super
chat hope sifu doesn't play like shaq
fool no not at all
you're safe there don't worry about it
an amazing show as always the lord's
brought it lord adam you gotta say the
people we get out of here
i appreciate everyone coming by man like
the
you know we we make a lot of jokes and
stuff but you guys come in every week
the amount of 10k shirts that you guys
bought just just to make fun of king is
absurd
absolutely like just think about it
the the realm has bought shirts to make
me play old ass games
has bought shirts
just because king forgot to put them all
for the store
with that narrative
at least you could say he tried
so what what i will do is i will talk to
the realm mm-hmm and see what we you
guys are due for another community
stream yeah i don't know what it's going
to be
uh you know i think
we got among us right
we have never got to that among us yeah
we got that and i want to throw somebody
out the airlock
it's all game pass too but the thing
about among us is it's one it requires
more than four people so maybe yeah we
can get more people from the patreon
yeah patreon members could play with
this yeah but keep in mind we we're
gonna have to we're gonna we have to get
some fillers out before we put you in
that because we'll probably have to do
on our discord because some of you be
loose and we still gotta we we we gotta
entertain the little ones like can't be
out there saying some crazy stuff
like i will say like some of y'all
meters
the community streams are a little bit
more relaxed and i owe people we still
don't want crazy stuff being said okay
get out of here
i appreciate everyone for coming through
keep in mind tomorrow at uh 6 p.m i will
be streaming battle toads
unless microsoft or
sony announced they bought another
multi-billion trillion whatever company
like
you know i will be streaming that and
then after that i i will be streaming uh
one more game i don't know what it's
gonna be yet i have to talk to the
person uh appreciate everyone coming
through we had up to like 900 and some
people we're growing so much i
appreciate all you guys for coming
through you know we have 581 likes
we are 19 likes away from 600 and
there's 630 people in here i feel like
there's 19 people in here that ain't
like this
that's just my opinion
yes the 600 likes and like this
this podcast no doubt lord
solve where can i find people find you
shout out to you
your new uh super chat friends
daddy song
thank you thank goodness lady saab was
elsewhere
but nah but thank you just like addie
said thank you guys like you know
we we love this dynamic between us four
right i love that but you guys make it
all that you guys are all in on
everything that we say we do and you
guys just run with it the fact that you
know you do you do things like keep us
here and keep super chatting to keep us
here and then you do this with the 10k
shirts it's hilarious but it what it
shows is how much you guys love what we
do so we we really really appreciate
that um
i am about to hop into my lord's minute
with lady april because uh ladies and
gentlemen mm-hmm i believe we got a
confirmation that gta 6 is in
development
lady april and i will have stuff to say
on that in a moment
so pretty much they're confirming we're
waiting six years for that game gotcha
yeah exactly shout out to fawn said lord
be attracted
[Laughter]
midway through the podcast i did go back
to color and that's cause i forgot
something if i wasn't color king can't
see me
clearly
shout out shout out to fonzo i just put
uh the link to his uh yeah go check him
out jump over that five o'clock guy he
has the homie pong soul
today yeah eventually we'll get you in
here we know we're gonna rock we'll
salute the father you're gonna set them
up thanks go live
nice no doubt lord king is always
finished um
yep no doubt we're gonna find people
find all your merch and what you have
going on
um this is this is i i've been wrongly
accused of things
today
i've showed my documentation
he did he did forgery
you know i really can't win for losing
here but
anyway um you can find me at uh dcx uh
fridays at 9 00 pm
that's dolph cast lex uh this week was a
great week you know started black
history month on 2xp
uh you know did attic show earlier
this was a very busy week um and
finished up with uh frames per second
with math and and and his team you know
with key and shout out to maven
belvedere yeah um
[Music]
beautiful stuff uh i love how the
community is
you guys are second to none you know i
may joke around and stuff like that and
regardless to what
you guys keep it uh cordial inside the
chat i mean you know to have so many
people in the chat reoccurring every
week
and you guys i've noticed also that you
guys have been going to lords of
gaming.net
uh you guys has really supported um
thank you for you know chiming in on my
lord's minute uh that i have talking
about the book of overfat um you know
saab and cognito's minutes that they
have up there um you know and addicts go
check that stuff out to give a deeper
insight off of some other stuff that we
don't normally talk about
and um kos is uh you know coming i just
uh did a couple of videos uh this week
i've been very busy this week so uh
thank you guys again
for all the support it's really humbling
that you guys even stick around this
long with us thank you so much yeah
salute man it's still about 600 in here
at the end of the show like that is
insane yeah that's absolutely to the
realm i mean just it's very humbling
it's always good to get back to the
essence but it's always humbling when i
start up the show king and it's like day
in there they engage with me and they
talk and again this is we have we're
blessed to have a community the realm is
like no other like you know what right
it's just it just is i've never seen
anything like that and i'm very humbled
that we have something like that that
supports us so you say that science you
know like the craziest feeling is
when you get likes on a podcast before
the podcast like when you just post it
on youtube and people liking it and when
you get super chats before during the
starting soon
said a word it's different and and trust
me it is appreciated it it makes coming
to work
like it don't even feel like work and we
love doing it and you know
all you guys do is prove that [ __ ] is
right about the little gus texas thank
you appreciate shout out to i forgot who
put that super chats off who said yo
thank you for not doing that because i
could listen yeah my daughter whatever
you know what's up look that was uh
nathan langston yeah shout to nate did
that meant a lot look we got a lot of
fun stuff planned up this month
maybe something big but i don't want to
jinx it we'll see what happens but it's
and we'll be streaming
uh the destiny raid yes yes yes we got
the dusty raid coming up march the 4th i
think yes we got all that good stuff
that's really all i got unless we got
any other business to take care of
everybody enjoy your sunday yo captain
tim case
what y'all got to do you know what i
said
we outta here peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
we really appreciate you guys
more than you know here's to 100k subs
now time to get messy what's with this
organic growth sony doesn't do organic
now me on the other hand oh my wife is
calling
all right
that's all though we ain't coming back
you guys won man you guys won
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you